ओके सो वी आर लाइव गाइस आई
थिंक यस लेट मी चेक वंस हम लाइव आ चुके
हैं मैं एक बार बस चेक कर
लूं ओके जस्ट
वेट प्लीज गाइस मुझे बता ऑडियो वीडियो सब
कुछ सही आ रही है क्या प्लीज प्लीज जल्दी
से बता दीजिए ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग इ
परफेक्टली
फाइन मैं इधर चेक भी कर लेता
[संगीत]
हूं ओके तो यहां आ चुका है नोटिफिकेशन सो
वी आर ओपनिंग इट एंड लेट्स चेक चलिए
सो मैं बिल्कुल बढ़िया मैं बिल्कुल बढ़िया
आप बताइए आप बताइए गुड इवनिंग
सबको
सबको गुड इवनिंग सबको गुड
इवनिंग ओके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग हैप्पी
रमदान राधे राधे जय श्री राम हेलो सबको
नमस्ते सभी भाई दोस्त जितने भी यहां पे
हैं एंड लेट एवरी बडी जॉइन हियर एंड आई
थिंक कि मेरा ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही है ओके
लेट मी
चेक ओके
ओके सबको गुड इवनिंग सब गुड इनि चलो
बढ़िया ओके सो गाइस काफी दिनों के बाद मिल
रहे हैं हम काफी दिनों के बाद हम मिल रहे
हैं एंड नोएडा वाली जो प्लान थी मेरी
शिफ्टिंग की वो बेसिकली कैंसिल आउट हो गई
है ड्यू टू सम रीजंस एंड आई रिटर्न टू माय
होम लाइक अगेन आई विल बी प्लानिंग इन सम
मंथ्स एंड देन आई विल बी डूइंग दैट थिंग
ऑफलाइन थिंग बट अभी के लिए कैंसिल हुआ है
ड्यू टू सम रीजंस ठीक है अब यहां पे गाइस
काफी दिनों के बाद मिल हैं तो थोड़ा सा अ
जो है इंटरेक्शन बनता है आप सबों से एंड
लेट्स लेट्स इंटरेक्ट विद यू गाइ फॉर सम
टाइम बिंग एंड वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग अ
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक टुडे ठीक है कहां
थे सर बहुत मिस किया आपको आपके क्लासेस को
इतनी इतना कि सब क्लासेस वापस दो बार देख
ली ओहो क्या बात है सारा भाई जोगिंदर
दैट्ची उम्मीद रखता हूं कि इतने दिनों के
गैप के बाद आप सबने क्लासेस पूरी कर ली
हैं जो भी 22 क्लासेस तक की जो वीडियोस थी
सबने देख ली है एंड अगर आपने इतने गैप के
बाद भी क्लासेस नहीं करी है कंप्लीट तो
इसमें तो फिर आपकी गलती है इसमें मेरी
गलती नहीं है एंड आपको यह गलती ठीक करनी
चाहिए एंड यू शुड कंप्लीट द क्लासेस वेरी
वेरी सून क्योंकि अब जो वीडियोस क्लासेस
जो है फिर से रेगुलर पहले जैसे आएंगी जैसे
रेगुलर आया करती थी एक दो दिन के गैप
गैप्स पे एंड मुझे बता दीजिए आप में से
कितने लोगों ने कंप्लीट 22 लेक्चर तक
कंप्लीट कर लिया है ईमानदारी से ऑनेस्टली
बताइएगा झूठ बिल्कुल मत बोलिएगा जल्दी बता
दीजिए
लेट मी
नो इंतहा हो गई इंतजार की चलो कैसे हो सब
लोग बढ़िया और बता दो जल्दी से सब लोगों
ने करा है या कंप्लीट या नहीं आप में से
कितने लोगों ने कर लिया कंप्लीट कितने
लोगों ने अभी नहीं करा है कौन सी नंबर पे
क्लासेस के कौन से क्लासेस पे हो अभी आप
एंड अगर आपने कंप्लीट कर लिया तो वो भी
बता दीजिए ठीक है थैंक यू गेमर मूड थैंक
यू ताहिर
पंकज आई आल्सो मिस्ड यू ऑल गाइस काफी टाइम
हो गया था एंड जब मैं अपना काम नहीं करता
हूं ना जब डिस्टरबेंसस हो जाती है
शिफ्टिंग के चक्कर में हो गई थी तो मेरे
को बहुत ज्यादा प्रॉब्लम होती है लाइक
मेरे को अच्छा नहीं लगता एंड आई मिस अ लॉट
तो सेम हाल मेरा भी है यहां पे चलिए बहुत
बढ़िया यहां पे 18 तक कंप्लीट हुआ सेवन तक
डन कर लिया कंप्लीट बहुत बढ़िया सिक्स
ओके यस यस यस यस अलाश आई केम बैक टू होम
एंड आई विल डिस्कस दिस विथ यू
शॉर्टली हैव यू नोटिस आई हैव फाइंड
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस अ आई थिंक आपने अगर
टैग किया होगा तो मैंने जरूर देखा होगा
दिव्यांश यस यस यस दिव्यांश सो यहां पे
मैं आपको दिखाना चाहता हूं हमारे एक
स्टूडेंट है एंड ये हमारे डेनिक्स का
वाज द पोस्ट फ्रॉम दिव्यांश एंड ही गॉट अ
अ लाइक फर्स्ट बग जो कि उन्हें मिला था
एक्सेसेस के फॉर्म में एंड इन्होंने हमें
टैग किया हुआ था सो मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन
मैंने यहां पे पोस्ट इनको कमेंट भी किया
हुआ है सो बहुत अच्छा लगता है ये देख के
एंड ये हमारा
twittersignin.com कंप्लीट कर रहे हैं
प्लीज उसको जल्दी से खत्म कीजिए जल्दी से
कंप्लीट कीजिए एंड इट विल बी वेरी वेरी
गुड फॉर यू ऑल ठीक है क्योंकि हम बहुत
ज्यादा कुछ अभी करने वाले हैं बहुत कुछ हम
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं और आज की जो क्लास
है आज की जो टॉपिक है वह बहुत ही शानदार
बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक जो है वह होने
वाली है एंड यह टॉपिक यह जो बग है जिसको
हम बोलते हैं सीएस आर एफ ठीक है जिसको हम
बोलते हैं क्रॉस
साइट
रिक्वेस्ट फॉर जरी ये बहुत ही शानदार वलने
बिलिटी है जो आपको हर एक वेब एप्लीकेशन
में मिलने के चांसेस हो जाते हैं अब ये
सीएसआरएफ जो बग है बेसिकली आईआर की तरह जो
भी बिगनर बग बाउंट हंटर्स होते हैं ना वो
इस वल्नरेबल के ऊपर हंट करते हैं एंड ये
फाइंड आउट भी करते हैं काफी लोगों को मिल
भी जाती है एंड काफी लोगों का पहला बग
सीएसआरएफ होता है यानी कि या तो आईडी आर
वो पहला बग उनको मिल जाता है या तो
सीएसआरएफ मिल जाता है सम टाइम्स दे गेट
एक्सेसेस आल्सो सम टाइम्स दे गेट
इंफॉर्मेशन डिस्क्लोजर और लाइक सेंसिटिव
डिस्क्लोजर ये सब भी चीजें आपको मिल जाती
है बट ये उनमें से एक है ठीक है अब यहां
पे अ सर मैंने कोर्स अभी स्टार्ट किया है
फिफ्थ लेक्चर पे पहुंचा हूं कैन यू प्लीज
टेल सम वेबसाइट्स लाइक ट्राई हैक मी फ्रॉम
वेयर आई कैन लर्न फॉर फ्री ट्राई हैक मी
का फ्री अल्टरनेटिव मैं आपको पहले ही बता
चुका हूं सभी को कि आप पोर्टस फगर के वेब
सिक्योरिटी एकेडमी पे आके एंड यहां पे आप
टॉपिक्स को कवर कर सकते हैं लैब्स को फ्री
में सॉल्व कर सते और भी बहुत सारे लब है
बक इ द गुड थिंग आई थिंक जो आपको जरूर से
जरूर कवर करना चाहिए तो आज के हम क्लास
में सीएसआरएफ के बारे में जानने वाले हैं
बहुत ही डिटेल बहुत ही कांसेप्चुअल बेस
ठीक है अब देखो मैं बग बांटी की जो
क्लासेस होती है ना बग बांटी की जो मैं
क्लासेस लेता हूं इसमें मेरा अप्रोच क्या
होता है आप सबको पता होना चाहिए कांसेप्ट
होता
है लैब्स होते हैं एंड यहां पर
प्रैक्टिकल्स होते हैं
आपके रियल वेबसाइट्स पर भी होते हैं ये
ठीक है अब यह कांसेप्ट सबसे ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है इस टाइम फ्रेम पे यह जो
कांसेप्ट है ना सबसे ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
अगर यह कांसेप्ट आपका क्लियर नहीं हुआ तो
आप फिर बहुत कुछ नहीं कर पाएंगे अगर आपका
कांसेप्ट क्लियर है ना बक बाउंटीज के अंदर
टॉपिक्स के ऊपर तो आप अलग-अलग
अप्रोचेबल तरीके यूज कर सकते हैं मेथड यूज
कर सकते हैं टू फाइंड दैट पर्टिकुलर वनबिल
एंड वही डिफरेंट मेथड जो है आपको अदर बग
बाउंट हंटर से डिफरेंट बनाती है यह याद
रखिएगा अब प्रो बग बाउंट हंटर ऐसे ही नहीं
बन जाएगा कोई उसके लिए आपकी मेथड आपका
तरीका सोचने का तरीका आपकी माइंडसेट वो
डिफरेंट होना चाहिए बाकी हंटर से तब जाके
आप बन सकते हैं डेफिनेटली बन सकते हैं ठीक
है ओके सो आई थिंक आई थिंक मेरे ख्याल से
कि बग बाउंट के अंदर में आपको सबसे जरूरी
चीज जो होनी चाहिए जो आपके दिमाग में
हमेशा रहनी चाहिए वो है मेथड
अगर मेथड जीी आपकी बढ़िया है तो आपको
डुप्लीकेट्स कम मिलेंगे एंड यू विल गेट
बाउंटीज इन शॉर्ट स्पैन ऑफ टाइम ओके नाउ
चलिए तो आज हम इस मेथड जीी को हम बढ़िया
से कवर करने वाले हैं सीएसआरएफ का अब
सीएसआरएफ का मतलब हम समझ लेते हैं इसका
फुल फॉर्म जो है क्रॉस साइट रिक्वेस्ट फॉर
जरी ठीक है अब यह कहीं ना कहीं कहीं ना
कहीं
जो सेम ओरिजिन पॉलिसी आपने पढ़ा था
प्रीवियस वीडियोस में सेम ओरिजिन प पॉलिसी
उसको
सरकमवेंट्स
करूंगा एक इसका मैं इसको मैं बहुत ही
सिंपली आपको समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं
सीएसआरएफ के थ्रू क्या हो सकती है ठीक है
ओके ओके हाय हाय हाय गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग सर टुडे इज माय फर्स्ट लाइव क्लास
प्लीज कांग्रेस मी अरे भैया कांग्रेस यार
लाइव क्लास के लिए भी कांग्रेस करना होता
है क्या ओके थैंक यू डीजे गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग अब यहां पर मैं आपको इसका मतलब
एजेक्ट समझा देता हूं सीएसआरएफ का मतलब
क्या होता है इस इस व बिलिटी के अंदर आपको
क्या फाइंड किस तरीके से चीजें फाइंड करनी
होती है मान लो चलो अब यहां पर मान लो एक
वेब एप्लीकेशन है लाइक एक टारगेट वेबसाइट
टारगेट वेबसाइट क्या है एक्सवा जड
कॉ यह टारगेट वेबसाइट मैं प्रैक्टिकली
थोड़ा समझाता हूं आपको ठीक है ठीक है अब
डीसीएसपी का न्यू बैच कब से डीडीएफएस का
न्यू बैच कब से स्टार्ट होगा आपको
अनाउंसमेंट में मिल जाएगी टेंशन मत लो
आपको प मिल जाएगा ओके टारगेट वेबसाइट एक क
एक्वा क के अंदर में कुछ फंक्शन है क्या
क्या फंक्शन है ईमेल का ईमेल मतलब इसके
अंदर में प्रोफाइल
अपडेट एक फंक्शन है जिसके अंदर में आप
ईमेल चेंज कर सकते
हैं पासवर्ड चेंज कर सकते हैं
यूजर नेम चेंज कर सकते हैं एंड पेमेंट
मेथड चेंज कर सकते हैं
पेमेंट सो जस्ट
वेट ओके यह क्या हुआ व्ट इ
दिस यह गायब हो गई क्या चलो तो यहां पर
मैं सीएस आरएफ की बात कर रहा था मैं यहां
पर अगेन चेंज हो गया ये तो यह हमारा एक
टारगेट है एक्सवा z.com
ठीक है एक्सवा ज कॉ के अंदर में
प्रोफाइल अपडेट फंक्शनल है जिसके अंदर में
आप ईमेल चेंज कर सकते
हो पासवर्ड चेंज कर सकते
हो लाइक पेमेंट मेथड चेंज कर सकते
हो देन यूजर नेम चेंज कर सकते
हो यह सारी चीज आप चेंज कर
ठीक है एक्सवा क यह हमारा टारगेट अब सीसर
लेबिलिटी फाइंड करने के लिए क्या करना
पड़ेगा जो अटैकर है
अटैकर
अटैकर इसका एक अकाउंट होगा
इस ठीक है अटैकर ने अकाउंट अकाउंट बनाया
लॉग इन कर लिया एक्सवा कॉ प एक्सवा कॉ
प ठीक है लॉग इन करने के बाद अपने
प्रोफाइल सेक्शन में जाता है
वो ओके एंड यहां पर ईमेल चेंज फंक्शनल पर
ईमेल चेंज वाले
फंक्शनालिस पट करता है इंटरसेप्ट करता है
किस चीज से किस चीज से इंटरसेप्ट करेगा
भाई यह तो आपको पता ही होगा इंटरसेप्ट किस
चीज से करेगा यह थोड़ा डार्क नहीं हो रहा
यह वाला डार्क ले लेते थोड़ बॉब सूट से
बॉब
सूट ईमेल चेंज फंटी को इंटरसेप्ट करेगा बब
शूट से एंड इसका एक सस आरफ पीसी जनरेट
करेगा पीसी जनरेट करेगा यह जो सीएस आरफ
पीसी होगी यह एक एचटीएमएल फाइल होगी जनरली
एचटीएमएल फाइल यानी कि उस फाइल का नाम
क्या हो सकता है सीएसआरएफ ड
एचटीएमएल जो कि ब्राउजर में एी क्यूट होती
है अब इस सीएसआर ड एटीएमएल फाइल के अंदर
में यह जो अटैकर है इसने क्या किया है
इसने ईमेल चेंज किया है अब चेंज फंशन के
अंदर में जब यह इंटरसेप्ट कर रहा है तो
इसका ईमेल आईडी इस इंटरसेप्ट वाली
रिक्वेस्ट में इसकी ईमेल आईडी खुद की तो
इसकी ईमेल आईडी क्या हो सकती है ईमेल इ
इक्वल टू एविल रेट
हैकर क य ईमेल आईडी दे रखी ठीक है इसने यह
वाली सीएस एटी फाइल बना द य पसी अब सीएस
आरफ लेबिलिटी
को एग्जीक्यूट कर के लिए प्रूफ करने के
लिए कि हा जी इस वेब एप्लीकेशन में सीएस
आर वटी एजिस्ट करती है यह सी वाली जो फाइल
है सड एटीएम यह भेजी जाएगी किसको विक्टिम
को विक्टिम को एंड विक्टिम वेन क्लिक ऑन
दिस फाइल जब विक्टिम इस पर क्लिक करेगा इन
ब्राउजर इन ब्राउजर जब विक्टिम इस पर
क्लिक करें इन ब्राउजर मैं इसको थोड़ा सा
यहां
से ऊपर में लिख देता हूं इसको इरेज करके
आई थिंक दिस इ द
इरेजर ताकि आपको दिख जाए
क्लियर ओके लेट म इनक्रीस द इरेज साइज
हियर
तो मैं इसको थोड़ा ऊपर लिख देता हूं ताकि
आपको दिख जाए यह चीज यह जो फाइल है
बेसिकली यह कहां भेजी जाएगी
भैया यह भेजी
जाएगी विक्टिम के पास अब विक्टिम जब इस पर
क्लिक करेगा ठीक है तो यह फाइल एग्जीक्यूट
होगी इन
ब्राउजर इन ब्राउजर जब एग्जीक्यूट होगी तो
यह जो एचटीएमएल स्क्रिप्ट
है इसके अंदर के कोड एग्जीक्यूट होंगे ठीक
है
वाइल यूजर इज वाइल यूजर
इज लगड
इन टू हिज
अकाउंट टू हि अकाउंट ए जैसे ही व एजीक्यू
होगा उस पर क्लिक करेगा तो यूजर
की यूजर ईमेल आईडी ईमेल आईडी
विल चेंज टू एविल रेट हैक कॉ पहले विक्टिम
की ईमेल थी टेस्ट टेस्ट
कॉ अब उसकी ईमेल आईडी हो गई ए hacker.com
ठीक है ट्स इट समझ में आ गया यह इतना
क्लियर हुआ जैसे हीय एग्जीक्यूट हुआ यहां
पर ईमेल आईडी चेंज हो गई विक्टिम की यानी
कि अब विक्टिम के अकाउंट में किसका ईमेल
है अटैकर का ईमेल है अब अटैकर क्या कर
सकता है इस ईमेल आईडी पर पासवर्ड रिसेट
रिक्वेस्ट सेंड करके उसकी पूरी अकाउंट
टेकओवर भी कर सकता है विक्टिम की एंड
दैट्ची लोग कि इतना आपको समझ में आया क्या
प्लीज लेट मी
नो इतना आपको समझ में आया क्या जल्दी बता
दीजिए
फटाफट प्लीज जल्दी फटाफट फटाफट डिड यू
अंडरस्टैंड
दिस या फॉर्म के थ्रू होगा मैं बताऊंगा
कैसे होगा अभी मैं बताऊंगा डिटेल में कैसे
ये कैसे ये चीज होगी कैसे ये चीज होगी
फॉर्म के थ्रू बॉब शूट के थ्रू यह भी मैं
आपको बताऊंगा अभी बट पहले इतना समझ में
आया कांसेप्ट समझ में आया यह बताइए मुझे
सभी लोग प्लीज ओके ओके ओके गट इट ग्रेट
चलिए बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत
सही ओके ग्रेट तो यह
एक कांसेप्ट था सीएसआरएफ का अब यह जो चीज
है इसके थ्रू सीएसआरएफ के थ्रू आप क्या कर
सकते हो बेसिकली व्ट यू कैन डू सीएसआरएफ
जब टी एजिस्ट करती है ना सीएस आरफ ज
लेबिलिटी एजिस्ट करती है इसके थ्रू व्ट यू
कैन डू यू कैन
बेसिकली यू कैन
बेसिकली चेंज ईमेल
आईडी ऑफ विक्टिम चेंज
पासवर्ड ऑफ विक्टिम देन यू कैन
चेंज यूजर
नेम ऑफ विक्टिम यू कैन चेंज पेमेंट मेथड्स
पेमेंट मेथड्स अगर कोई पेमेंट मेथ एजिस्ट
करती है ठीक है कमेंट चेंज कमेंट्स अगर
कोई कमेंट सपोर्टेड फील्ड है कहीं पर
कमेंट वगर है उसको आप चेंज कर सकते हो यू
कैन चेंज
लाइक
एनी
डाटा
ट ट इज ऑफ
द
विक्टिम
ऑन देयर
अकाउंट मतलब उसके अकाउंट पर जो भी डाटा
चेंजेबल है जो भी अपडेटेबल डाटास है उनको
आप चेंज कर सकते हो एंड दिस व्ट सीएसआरएफ
डज सीएसआरएफ इज अ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक याद
रखिएगा क्लाइंट साइड
अटप ठीक है एंड आप कोई डाटा इससे चुरा
नहीं सकते याद रखिएगा यू कैन नॉट कैन नॉट
गैदर सम लाइक यू कैन नॉट स्टील एनी डाटा
फ्रॉम दिस अटैक क्योंकि ये क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक है तो आप इससे डाटा नहीं चुरा सकते
हो बट उसके अंदर मॉडिफिकेशन कर सकते हो यू
कैन मॉडिफाई दैट पर्टिकुलर पैरामीटर सॉरी
द पर्टिकुलर पैरामीटर्स द पर्टिकुलर डाटा
इनसाइड अ विक्टिम अकाउंट अब जब बग बाउंडी
प्रोग्राम्स पे आप सीएस आरएफ फाइंड करते
हो ना तो उसको रिपोर्ट कैसे
करोगे अब यह क्वेश्चन तो आपका हो सकता है
ना कि सर यूजर क्यों सीए आ एड
हुआ कि यूजर को हमने हम इंड्यूस कर रहे
हैं फोर्स कर रहे हैं कि भैया इस पर क्लिक
करो तभी ये लेबिलिटी एजिस्ट करती है या हम
उसको दिखा पाएंगे नहीं ऐसा नहीं है
सीएसआरएफ जो एटीएमएल फाइल बनेगी ये तो
मैंने एक सिंपल सा बताया कि यूजर उसपे
क्लिक करें एंड देन ये चीज हो जाए लेकिन
यहां पे हम एक ऑटो
सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट ऐड करेंगे इस फाइल के
अंदर
में जिसके थ्रू जैसे ही यूजर उस
csrss.exe और उसको अलग से उसको एग्जीक्यूट
करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी ऑटोमेटिक
बैकग्राउंड में वो एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा
ठीक है ट्स इट ट टस द
थिंग
ओके समझ में
आया नाम क्या है अरे नाम मेरा है नितेश
माय नेम इज
सिंह बगली सर यहां मेरी किस्मत है मुझे
आपकी वीडियोस मिली बिकॉज मैंने पूरा
youtube0 को ऐसे पढ़ा रहा है थैंक यू एंड
ऐसे ही पढ़ते रहे बस मजा आता रहेगा ठीक है
ओके बढ़िया बढ़िया मितुन
जय हां एचटीएमएल फाइल अब देखो पीसी में
कैसे अब मान लो पीसी में आपको कैसे करना
है यह तो दिमाग में आगा ना कि भाई पीसी को
कैसे बनाएंगे जो प्रूफ ऑफ कांसेप्ट होगा
जब हम बग बाउटी प्राम को सीएस आर व बिलिटी
रिपोर्ट करेंगे तो किस तरीके से रिपोर्ट
करेंगे उनको कैसे दिखाएंगे मतलब विक्टिम
से क्लिक करवा के उसका कैसे वीडियो
रिकॉर्ड होगा क्या नहीं जब आपको पीसी सेंड
करना होगा सीएसआरएफ के लिए सीएसआरएफ के
लिए तो आपको क्या करना है एस अटैकर आपको
दो अकाउंट क्रिएट करने है अकाउंट वन
अकाउंट वन एंड अकाउंट टू यह दोनों अकाउंट
आप ही क्रिएट करेंगे विक्टिम के साइड से
कुछ नहीं होगा पहला अकाउंट जो होगा वो
अटैकर का अकाउंट होगा दूसरा अकाउंट जो
होगा वह विक्टिम का अकाउंट आप ही क्रिएट
करेंगे अटैकर के अंदर में लॉग इन
करेंगे एंड ईमेल चेंज या जो भी चेंज
फंक्शन है उसको इंटरसेप्ट
करेंगे ठीक है इंटरसेप्ट कर लिया अब वहां
से आप क्या करेंगे
सीएसआरएफ पीओ जनरेट करेंगे बब शूट
से एंड देन उसको विक्टिम वाले अकाउंट में
लॉग इन करके एंड एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे
एग्जीक्यूट
सीएसआरएफ
एचटीएमएल इन
विक्टिम
ब्राउजर
सेशन ठीक है लॉगिन के बाद अगर यहां पे ये
चेंज होते हैं डिटेल जैसे ईमेल का किया है
तो ईमेल चेंज होना चाहिए पासवर्ड का किया
पासवर्ड चेंज होना चाहिए कोई पेमेंट मेथड
अपडेट कर रहे वो चेंज होना चाहिए अगर यह
होता है तो फिर सीए सार लेबिलिटी यहां पर
एजिस्ट करती है एंड देन यू कैन इजली
रिपोर्ट बाय रिकॉर्डिंग द वीडियो या जो भी
आपको स्टेप वाइज
रिप्रोडक्टिव आपको समझाने की कोशिश करता
हूं कि ये चीजें एक्चुअली काम करती कैसे
हैं यह हमें देखना है ओके चलिए तो यहां
पे
सॉरी पोर्ट फगर प आ जाइएगा वेब सिक्योरिटी
अकेडमी पर लेटेस्ट टॉपिक्स में ऑल टॉपिक्स
आइएगा क्लाइंट साइड में आपको यहां पर
क्रॉस साइट रिक्वेस्ट फॉर जरी का जो है
ऑप्शन मिल
जाएगा यहां आएंगे यहां पर आपको इसकी
डेफिनेशन मिलेगी जैसा मैंने आपको बताया
सेम चीजें होंगी सीएसआरएफ इज अ वेब
सिक्योरिटी व बिलिटी दैट अलाउ एन अटैकर टू
इंड्यूस यूजर्स टू परफॉर्म एक्शन ट डू न
दे डू नॉट इंटेंड टू परफॉर्म मतलब वो
एक्शन परफॉर्म करना जो वह चाहते ही नहीं
है बस वही काम है क्लाउज एन अटैकर टू
पार्शियली
सरकमवेंट्स
पी वाली वीडियो बनाई थी जो मैंने आपको वो
समझाया था यह आपको मैं दिखा देता हूं ताकि
आपको समझ में आ जाए
कि
यहां पर वीडियो सेक्शन में
जाइएगा
सॉरी सीआरएस एंड सीएसपी के बारे में मैंने
आपको बताया था इस वीडियो को जरूर देखिएगा
इससे आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि मैं किस
बारे में बात कर रहा हूं उसको सर्वेंट
करने के लिए यह किया जाता है यहां पे एंड
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं जैसे कोई एक
यूआरएल है एंड यहां एक पैरामीटर है ईमेल इ
प @ एयरनेट ठीक है ईमेल एड्रेस चेंज किया
एंड ईमेल चेंज करने के बाद अकाउंट जो है
वो कंप्रोमाइज हो जाती है ठीक है अब देखो
यहां पे क्या होता है इन सक्सेसफुल
सीएसआरएफ अटैक द अटैकर कॉसेस द विक्टिम
यूजर टू कैरी आउट एन एक्शन
अनइंटेंशनली एक ऐसा एक्शन जो अनइंटेंशनली
है इंटेंशन नहीं है उसको परफॉर्म करने का
विक्टिम को नहीं चाहिए भाई वो चीज हो बट
विक्टिम कर दिया विक्टिम ने एग्जीक्यूट कर
दी वो हो गया आपका सीएसआरएफ ठीक है
राइट गॉट इट चलिए अब देखिए यहां पे फॉर
एग्जांपल दिस माइट बी एबल टू चेंज द ईमेल
एड्रेस ऑफ देयर अकाउंट टू चेंज देयर
पासवर्ड हा टू मेक फंड ट्रांसफर मतलब
व्हाट एवर देयर इज व्हाट एवर द
फंक्शनैलिटी इज देयर इन द विक्टिम्स
अकाउंट ईमेल एड्रेस चेंज हो सकता है
प्रोफाइल का कोई भी डिटेल चेंज हो सकता है
पासवर्ड चेंज हो सकता है अपडेट हो सकती है
पेमेंट मेथड अपडेट हो सकती है कोई भाई
कहीं पे कुछ कमेंट कर रहा है वो चीज आपकी
चेंजेबल जो भी चेंजेबल चीज है जो भी
पैरामीटर है आप उस पैरामीटर को बेसिकली
इंटरसेप्ट करके एंड वहां सीओ सीओ सॉरी सीए
सार जो आपका
पीओसीओ ऑटो सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट डालोगे एंड
अगर वो वि टम उसको एग्जीक्यूट करता है एंड
वो चीज एग्जीक्यूट होती है वहां सीएसआरएफ
वलने बिलिटी एजिस्ट करती है जनरली क्या
होता है सीएसआरएफ वने बिलिटी लॉग इन एंड
लॉग आउट पेजेस पे बहुत कॉमन होते हैं
ऑलमोस्ट हर एक वेब एप्लीकेशन में 10 में
से पांच छह वेब एप्लीकेशन में लॉग इन लॉग
आउट सीएसआरएफ आपको मिल जाएगा बट
अनफॉर्चूनेटली जो वेब
एप्लीकेशन जो बेसिकली बग बाउटी
प्रोग्राम्स है वो लॉग इन लॉग आउट
सीएसआरएफ को एक्सक्लूड कर देते हैं यह आप
मान के चलिए ठीक है द लाइक दे एक्सक्लूड
दोज अ फंक्शनालिस लाइक लॉग इन लॉग आउट
सीएसआरएफ तो आपको लॉग इन लॉग आउट वाली
सीएसआरएफ कहीं पे मिलती है तो उसको थोड़ा
सा आप लाइक इग्नोर मारिए मैं किस बारे में
बात कर रहा हूं मैं आपको दिखाता हूं जैसे
कि मैं क्या करता हूं यस आई एम गोइंग हियर
एंड आई एम गोइंग टू टेस्ट ph.com ठीक है
अब मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं देखो मैं
आपको एक एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं मैं अपनी बॉब
शूट को स्टार्ट कर देता हूं ये वाली चीज
एक्सक्लूड होती है ये चीज आपकी वैलिड नहीं
होगी अगर आप रिपोर्ट भी कर करते हैं तो
मैं आपको बस एग्जांपल बता देता हूं ताकि
आप इस वाले पचड़े में मत पए बहुत लोग लॉग
इन लॉग आउट वाले सीएसआरएफ के चक्कर में
बहुत टाइम वेस्ट कर देते हैं अपना एंड वो
मैक्सिमम लेबिलिटी जो प्रोग्राम होती है
बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम उससे एक्सक्लूड करके
रखे रहते हैं वो ठीक है नाउ व्हाट आई विल
डू मैं इस पे आया मैं यहां पे प्रोफाइल पे
चलता हूं मैं यहां पे मैं यहां पे क्या
करता हूं अ सिंपली व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू
डू अ सी मैंने यहां पे टेस्ट टेस्ट में
लॉग इन कर
लिया मैंने यहां पे सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
गाइस टेस्ट टेस्ट में मैंने लॉग इन किया
एंड मैं यहां पे लॉगइन कर दिया ठीक है चलो
यहां पे लॉगइन हो चुका मैं अब यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा लॉग आउट टेस्ट यह वाली
प यह वाली ऑप्शन आ रही है आपके पास मैं
क्या करता हूं मैं यहां पर चलता हूं
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर लेता हूं आई थिंक
मैंने शायद ब सूट प्रॉक्सी ऑन नहीं कि है
तो अब मैं ऑन कर देता हूं ठीक है डन नाउ
आई एम इंटरसेप्टिंग इट आई एम गोइंग एंड
क्लिक ऑन लगो टेस्ट जैसे ही मैंने लॉग आउट
टेस्ट प क्लिक किया यहां पे आपको लॉड
पीएपी आपको एक रिक्वेस्ट गईल पीएचपी को
एंड दिस इज द कुकी द लॉगिन कुकी जो यहां
पे आपको जा रही है यहां पे बेसिकली जो
सर्वर ने रिक्वेस्ट करी होगी ओबवियसली नाउ
व्हाट आई विल डू मैं यहां पे सिंपल राइट
क्लिक करता हूं यहां पे जस्ट वी आर ट्राइट
सी यहां पे इंगेजमेंट टूल्स पे चलते हैं
यहां पे एंड जनरेट सीएसआरएफ पीओ कर देते
हैं ठीक है जनरेट सीएसआरएफ पीओ मैंने यहां
पे क्लिक किया एंड यहां पे जैसे ही मैंने
क्लिक किया
दैट्ची है यहां पे क्या है ये सबमिट
रिक्वेस्ट लॉड पप एंड
दैट्ची पे इंक्लूड ऑटो सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट को
इनेबल कर दूंगा एंड यहां पे फिर से मैं
इसको री जनरेट करूंगा इस
पीओसीआई ऑटो सबमिट वाली स्क्रिप्ट ऐड हो
गई ठीक है आपके इसमें पीसी में अब मैं
इसको एटीएमएल को कॉपी कर लूंगा यहां पे
एचटीएल कोड जो यहां पे मेरे पास आई है
मैंने इसको कॉपी कर लिया मैं इसको सिंपल
सा सिंपल सा यहां पे क्लोज कर देता हूं
एंड मैं इस रिक्वेस्ट को यहां पे ड्रॉप कर
देता हूं ड्रॉप किया मैंने चलिए बढ़िया है
यहां पे मैं अगेन बैक कर देता हूं यहां पे
लॉग आउट वाली पेज यहां पे आपके पास आ चुकी
है नाउ व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू आई एम
गोइंग टू कंस्ट स्ट्रक्ट सीएसआरएफ पीओ
एटीएमएल जिसके लिए मुझे क्या चाहिए मुझे
जिसके लिए चाहिए सिंपल सा एक कोई सा भी
टेक्स्ट एडिटर ठीक है सो लेट्स लेट्स ओपन
अ टेक्स्ट एडिटर लेट्स ओपन
नोटपैड हां जी तो यह रहा नोटपैड यहां पे
मैंने ये जो हमारा एटीएमएल कोड था वो हमने
पेस्ट कर दिया यहां पे एंड मैं इसको सेव
कर लेता हूं एंड मैं इसका नाम वही दे देता
हूं सिंपल सीएसआर एड एटीएमएल
सड एटीए हमने कर दिया एंड यहां पे हम यहां
पे सेव कर देते हैं ठीक है इसको सेव किया
हमने
दैट्ची को ऑफ कर देना है यहां पे प्रॉक्सी
को ऑफ कर दिया मैंने यहां पे अब इसको मैं
firefox.exe
इसको रीलोड करता हूं यहां पे सिंपल मैं
यहां पे प्रोफाइल पे चलता हूं सिंपल सा
यहां पे अब यहां पे क्या आ रहा है यू हैव
बीन लॉक्ड आउट सी यू बैक सून यानी कि हमने
जो सी सीएसआरएफ
पीओसीओ सबमिट रिक्वेस्ट इनेबल किया एंड
यहां पे जैसे ही ओपन हुआ ब्राउजर सेशन में
यहां पे विक्टिम के साइड से क्या हुआ यहां
पे गाइस व्हाट हैपेंड उसका सेशन लॉग आउट
हो गया ये एक सिंपल सा लॉगइन लॉग आउट
सीएसआरएफ अवेलेबिलिटी है जो कि आउट ऑफ
स्कोप होती है मोस्ट ऑफ द बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम्स के तरफ से तो इन चक्रों में
मत पढ़ना यह बहुत ही कॉमन चीज है मोस्ट ऑफ
द बक बाउटी प्रोग्राम्स हैव दिस इशू ठीक
है वो इसको इंपैक्टफुल नहीं मानते राइट
चलिए
[संगीत]
ओके
ओके आर यू गेटिंग गाइस आप सबको समझ में आई
ये चीज आप सबको समझ में आया यह चीज आप
सबको समझ में आई प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए
प्लीज
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस डिड यू गेट
दिस आप सबको समझ में
आई डिड यू गेट दिस प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए
प्लीज
यस
ओके जिनके थोड़ी सी ऊपर से गई मैं आपसे
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं प्लीज एक बार वीडियो
को रिकॉर्डेड जो सेशन होगा उसको देखिएगा
आपको क्लियर हो जाएगा वो जो मैं आपको यहां
पे समझाना चाह रहा था ठीक
है ठीक है
पीओसीओ के लिए मैंने यहां राइट क्लिक करके
एंड सिंपल
पीओसीओ मैं आपको दिखाऊं वो चीज अभी मैं
आपको और भी क्लियर कर दूंगा टेंशन मत लोय
एक सिंपल सा लॉग इन लॉग आउट था
एंड या बिकॉज दिस इ लॉग लग सारे जनरली य
जो होती है वो आउट ऑफ स्कोप होता है जैसे
मैं अगर चलता हू ना बक क्राउड प लेट्स गो
ब बकड के प्रोग्राम प चलते है ठीक
है लेट्स गो टू द कक
प्रोग्राम एंड यहां कोई भी एक प्रोग्राम
उठा लेते हैं जैसे रैपिड वाला प्रोग्राम
है इसको उठा लेते हैं लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज
अ इन स्कोप आइटम्स
गिवन ये आउट ऑफ स्कोप है यहां
पे देखो यहां पे लिखा है क्रॉस सेट
रिक्वेस्ट फॉर जरी ऑन अनऑथेंटिकेटेड
फॉर्म्स और फॉर्म्स विथ नो सेंसिटिव
एक्शंस कोई ऐसा सेंसिटिव एक्शन ना हो तो
वहां पे ये चीज वैलिड नहीं है तो लॉगइन
लॉगआउट वाली जो है वो सेंसिटिव नहीं मानी
जाती है बट हां सेंसिटिव कौन माना जाता है
अकाउंट के अंदर कुछ चेंज आप कर पा रहे हैं
यू कैन मेक सम चेंजेज इनसाइड द अकाउंट देन
दैट इज कंसीडर्ड एज अ सेंसिटिव ठीक है
चलिए अब इसको हम एकदम से लाइव पहले देखते
हैं अब यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं हाउ डज
सीएसआरएफ वर्क इसके बारे में डिटेल्स है
किस तरीके से काम करती है इसको आप पढ़
सकते हैं यहां पे आके मुझे एक्सप्लेन करने
की जरूरत नहीं है मैं फंक्शनल प्रोसेस
एग्जीक्यूशन प ज्यादा ध्यान देता हूं तो
मैं आपको वो चीज समझाता हूं ठीक है
चलिए सब बर्ब शूट का एक्टिवेशन वीडियो फिर
से डाल दीजिए
नहीं है क्या आप लोग देखिए ना ैनो को आप
लोगों ने जवाइन नहीं करा है क्या आप लोग
ैनब शूट एक्टिवेशन वीडियो ऑलरेडी डाल रखी
है गाइस अगर आपने नहीं देखा है अभी तक
मतलब वाली वीडियो नहीं आपको मिला है तो
आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट है जो भी वीडियोस आ रही
है ना अभी हमारे चैनल के ऊपर में जैसे मैं
अभी ओपन करके दिखा देता हूं आपको ठीक
है सो आप चैनल जो वीडियोस आती है उस परे
चले
जाइएगा लाइव वाले सेक्शन में ए एंड जैसे
कि मान लो यह वीडियो है या 20 सेकंड ये
वाली वीडियो है लाइव वाली इसको ओपन कर
लीजिएगा इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा
यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको यहां पे
whatsapp-web स सार वने बिलिटी विथ नो
डिफेंसेस ठीक है चलिए हम इसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं नाउ व्हाट इज देयर वी हैव टू
अंडरस्टैंड दिस दिस लैब्स ईमेल चेंज
फंक्शन इज वल्नरेबल टू सीएसआरएफ सोचो ये
कितनी बड़ी कितनी शानदार और खतरनाक
लेबिलिटी है ना जिसका आप जिसका आप आईडिया
नहीं लगा सकते सच बता रहा हूं मैं यू कैन
नॉट इमेजिन हाउ डेंजरस दिस वटी कैन बी फॉर
फॉर अ विक्टिम फॉर अ यूजर सोचो आप अपने
सेम वेब पे सेम वेबसाइट प मान लो यार मतलब
जस्ट एग्जांपल के लिए मैं बता रहा हूं एक
एग्जांपल के लिए ले लो ना
एग्जीक्यूट करा लिया अब विक्टिम ने अपने
अकाउंट में
बैंकिंग वेबसाइट्स में भी आप थोड़ा सा
सेफ्टी के साथ अ अ जो है अ बैंकिंग जो
वेबसाइट्स हैं उसको यूज कीजिएगा क्योंकि
ऐसे केसेस वहां पे भी पॉसिबल है आप किसी
बैंक वेबसाइट में लॉग इन है एंड वहां पे
अगर सही अच्छी डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म नहीं है
सीएसआरएफ के अगेंस्ट तो वहां पे अगर आपने
किसी ऐसे मलेशियन लिंक पे क्लिक किया जो
कि एक ऑटो सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट के साथ आती है
जो आपके बैंकिंग के डिटेल्स चेंज कर सकती
है यूजर डिटेल्स चेंज कर सकती है फिर आपके
लिए वो प्रॉब्लम हो सकती है या तो आपका
यूजर नेम हो गया ट्रांजैक्शन पासवर्ड हो
गया व्हाट एवर देर इट इज ठीक है तो ये बात
आपको समझना
पड़ेगा ओके चलिए थैंक्स टू द वेरी मच
थैंक्स टू वेरी म थैंक्स टू वेरी मच टू
स्टार्ट दिस सीरीज बिकॉज दिस इज वेरी वेरी
हेल्पफुल टू क्रिएट माय फ्यूचर ए बंटा
वेलकम
ब्रदर वेलकम चलिए अब यहां पे है दिस लैब्स
ईमेल चेंज फंक्शनालिस एसआरएफ ठीक है भाई
टू सॉल्व द लैब क्राफ्ट सम एचटीएमएल दैट
यूज अ सीएस सफ अटप टू चेंज द व्यूवर्स
ईमेल एड्रेस एंड अपलोड इट टू योर
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर यू कैन लॉग इन टू योर ओन
अकाउंट यूजिंग द फॉलोइंग डिटेल्स विनर एंड
पीटर चलिए एक्सेस लैब्स को लैब को एक्सेस
करते हैं क्या दिक्कत है एक्सेस करते हैं
लैब को देखते हैं क्या हो सकता है तो लैब
इज ओपनिंग एंड पर्गर के लैब्स ट्राई हैक
मी के लैब्स आपको जरूर करने चाहिए मेरे
ख्याल से पगर के बिल्कुल फ्री लैब्स हैं
यू विल गेट टू लर्न अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स अगर
आपने सारे लैब्स कंप्लीट किए हैं तो एंड
ट्रा हैक मी तो खैर है ही अच्छा
और बहुत जल्द शायद हम अपना लैब बहुत जल्द
लंच करेंगे थोड़ी सी चीजें बची हुई है
उसमें फ्रंट एंड का वह जैसे ही कंप्लीट
होगा व विल बी लंचिंग आवर ओन सीटीएफ लैब्स
ठीक है चलिए तो यर वी केम माय अकाउंट प
चलते हैं अकाउंट में लॉग इन कर लेते हैं
विनर एंड पीटर लॉगिन है हमारा तो
लेट्स विनर पीटर एंड क्लिक ऑन द लॉग इन
नेवर अब य ईमेल चेंज फंक्शनल है जो रेबल
है ठीक है भैया तो चलिए यहां पे हम ईमेल
चेंज प चलते हैं यहां पे चलते हैं टेस्ट @
test.com
ठीक है ये हमने किया अब हम इसको अपडेट
करेंगे बट इसके पहले यहां पे अभी जो ईमेल
आईडी है ये वाली ईमेल आईडी ठीक है अभी हम
इसको अपडेट करने से पहले ठीक
है
सो कक द बॉक्स भी अच्छा है यू कैन गो विद
दैट
आल्सो ओके देयर इज अ चैट
लेट्स
सी व्ट
दिस हेलो नितेश सर आई फाउंड ग मैप एपीआई
की इन टारगेट जेएस फाइल ड्यूरिंग वाचिंग
योर जेएस सेंसिटिव वीडियो ठीक है एंड आई
फाउंड दिस ग मैप एपीआई की इज वल्नरेबल सो
एनी इंपैक्ट ऑफ दिस ग मैप एपीआई की सर विन
सिंपल सा फंडा है ग मैप एपीआई की आपको
मिली है तो
आप वल्नरेबल है
यह से मिल गया आपको सेंसिटिव इंफो मान लो
तो व वल्नरेबल है यह आप डिसाइड अभी कैसे
कर देंगे जब तक आपने इंपैक्ट शो नहीं किया
अब आप उस गल मैप एपीआई की का यूज करके
किसी तरह का कोई इंपैक्ट कर सकते हैं यूजर
अकाउंट के तरफ से देन वो ट्राई कीजिए एंड
अगर वह होती है तभी वह कंसीडर होगा वनरे
बिलिटी की वैलिड बक की तर नहीं तो फिर व
कंसीडर नहीं हो ठीक
है ओके चलिए यहां पर हमने किया अब अपडेट
ईमेल आईडी करने से पहले हम क्या करेंगे
यहां पे इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर देते हैं एंड
इसको हमने यहां पे अपडेट पे क्लिक किया
जैसे ही अपडेट पे क्लिक किया यहां पे हम
चलते हैं बब शूट पे एंड यहां पे हम करते
हैं फॉरवर्ड एंड हियर वी गेट द रिक्वेस्ट
माय अकाउंट चेंज ईमेल ठीक है ये वाली
रिक्वेस्ट हमें मिली माय अकाउंट चेंज ईमेल
वाली रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है
दैट्ची जनरेट करना है पीसी जनरेट करनी है
तो व्हाट आई विल डू राइट क्लिक करना है
आपको जब सी सीएसआरएफ जनरेट करनी है राइट
क्लिक करनी है एंगेजमेंट टूल्स पे जानी है
जनरेट सीएसआरएफ पीओ पे आपको क्लिक करना है
अब यहां पे जब आप क्लिक करोगे तो यहां पे
आपको देखोगे आप देखोगे ईमेल टेस्ट @
test.com है तो इसको मैं मान लो टेस्ट या
टेस्ट वन जो भी करना है कर दो यहां पे
मैंने ईमेल आईडी ये कर दी एंड यहां ऑप्शन
पे जाएंगे इंक्लूड ऑटो सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट पे
क्लिक करेंगे जैसे ही मैंने क्लिक किया
यहां पे री जनरेट प क्लिक करेंगे ये जनरेट
होके यहां पे आ चुकी है नाउ कॉपी कर लेंगे
इस एचटीएमएल कोड को हमने कॉपी कर लिया
यहां पे अब हम अगेन अपने यहां पे विक्टिम
के ऊपर यहां पे जाएंगे एंड यहां जाएंगे हम
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर के ऊपर में ठीक है
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर पे जाएंगे यहां पे
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं फिलहाल के
लिए और लेट्स ड्रॉप द रिक्वेस्ट इंटरसेप्ट
ऑफ कर देते हैं लेट्स गो हियर ओके यहां हम
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर पे जाएंगे एक्सप्लोइट
सर्वर पे जैसे ही जाते हैं यहां हम बॉडी
में अंदर हमारी जो रिक्वेस्ट थी यानी
हमारी जो एचटीएमएल कोड थी उसको हमने यहां
पे पेस्ट किया जो हमारा सीएसआरएफ एचटीएमएल
कोड था यहां हमने पेस्ट कर दिया अब यहां
पर आप देख सकते हैं वैल्यू जो है ईमेल
आईडी की एंड यहां पर हमें स्टोर पर क्लिक
कर देना है हम स्टोर पर क्लिक करेंगे
लेट्स वेट हमने स्टोर पर क्लिक कर दिया
स्टोर हो गई अब इस एक्सप्लोइट को विक्टिम
को डिलीवर कर देते हैं डिलीवर एक्सप्लोइट
टू
विक्टिम या एंड जैसे ही हमने डिलीवर किया
इट्स हियर कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्व द लैब
तो आपने लैब को सॉल्व कर दिया ट्स इट खत्म
हो गया आपका लैब सॉल्व हो चुका है एंड नाउ
यू हैव बेसिकली चेंज द ईमेल आईडी इन इन अह
ईमेल आईडी यूजिंग सीएसआरएफ वने एबिलिटी तो
आपने यहां पे जैसे ही किया टेस्ट अब जो
उसकी अकाउंट की जो डिटेल होगी वह टेस्ट वन
जो होगी वह हो चुकी होगी जो कि आपने चेंज
किया है
दैट्ची से यह काम करती है ठीक है यह आपको
समझ में अब आ चुका होगा आई थिंक इस लैब से
आपको क्लियर हो चुका होगा इस लैब में कुछ
भी नहीं था बहुत सिंपल सा था यहां पे यहां
पे हमने एक्सेस लैब को किया हमने अकाउंट
को लॉगइन किया उसके बाद हमने
पीओसीआई डाल दी जो ईमेल आईडी हमें अटैकर
का ईमेल आईडी जो था वो डाल दिया एंड उसके
बाद हमने क्या किया हमने सिंपल यहां पे
इसको एग्जीक्यूट करा दिया एंड
दैट्ची चेंज हो चुकी थी चलिए यह तो आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा यह क्लियर हुआ आपका जो
मैंने अभी यहां पे किया आपको समझ में आया
एवरी बडी गॉट प्लीज लेट मी नो डिड यू
गेट
इजी था ठीक है बढ़िया हा इजी होगा ना यार
अभी तो पहला ही लब था हाय सर कैन यू
स्टार्ट बग हंटिंग पैरेलली फॉलोइंग योर
वीडियोस ड ट बी हेल्पफुल और शुड कंप्लीट द
कोर्स फर्स्ट प्लीज बी हेल्पफुल विथ योर
रिप्लाई मतलब आप पैरेलल इसको चला सकते हो
कोई इशू नहीं अरु यू कैन गो पैरेलल विस
डेफिनेटली यू कैन गो पलल विस ठीक
है ऑटो जनरेट सीएसआरएफ टोकन इज ओनली
अवेलेबल इन b प्र या ऑब् वियस यूज़ करो ना
b प्र क्या दिक्कत है कोई इशू नहीं है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं या तो आप ये वाला यूज कर सकते
हो ये वाला मेथड ट्रा अगर आपके पास बब शूट
का प्रो वर्जन नहीं है ना तो आप ये अ हिंट
पे शायद यहां पे आपको मिलेगा नहीं
सॉल्यूशन में शायद मिल जाएगा यहां पे अ ये
रहा इफ यू आर यूजिंग बब शूट कम्युनिटी
एडिशन यूज द फॉलोइंग एचटीएमएल टेंप्लेट यू
कैन गेट द रिक्वेस्ट यूआरएल बाय राइट
क्लिक एंड सिलेक्टिंग कॉपी यूआरएल तो ये
वाला जो है आप ट्राई कर सकते हो पर्टिकुलर
एचटीएमएल टेंप्लेट अगर आपके पास कम्युनिटी
एडिशन है तो ठीक है अदर वाइज प्रो में तो
ऑप्शन है ही
चलिए हां हां कर सकते हो अगर आप अगर आपसे
सॉल्व नहीं होता है ना बाय चांस अगर आप
खुद से नहीं कर पा रहे हो तो आप इसका
सॉल्यूशन या हिंट दे पहले हिंट देख लो
हिंट हिंट देख लो नहीं समझ में आ रहा है
फिर सॉल्यूशन देख लो सॉल्यूशन में आपको
स्टेप मिल जाएंगे आप इसको देख के सॉल्व कर
लो एक बार सॉल्व कर लोगे तो आपका वो
क्लियर हो जाएगा अगर फिर भी नहीं हो रहा
है तो कम्युनिटी सॉल्यूशंस में वीडियो
सॉल्यूशंस आपको मिल जाएंगे आप इन वीडियो
सॉल्यूशंस को देख के सॉल्व कर सकते हैं
सिंपल ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे एक और लैब
की तरफ चलते हैं जो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है वी
ल सीस आरफ लैब लेट्स
गो ओके अब यहां पे आते हैं यहां पे आते
हैं सीएसआरएफ सीएसआरएफ वेर टोकन वैलिडेशन
डिपेंड्स ऑन रिक्वेस्ट मेथड ठीक है अब ये
भी एक तरीका है क्या है ये दिस लैब्स ईमेल
चेंज फंक्शन टी इज वल्नरेबल टू सीएसआरएफ
ठीक है सीएसआरएफ से वल्नरेबल है इट
अटेम्प्ट्स टू ब्लॉक सीएसआरएफ अटैक्स बट
ओनली अप्लाइज डिफेंसेस टू सर्टेन टाइप ऑफ
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है टू सॉल्व द लैब यूज योर
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर टू होस्ट एन एचटीएमएल
पेज दैट यूसेज अ सीएसआरएफ अटैक टू चेंज द
व्यूवर्स ईमेल एड्रेस यू कैन लॉग इन टू
योर अकाउंट यूजिंग दिस दिस दिस ठीक है समझ
में आ गया चलिए अब देखिए अब देखिए यहां पे
हम चलते हैं एक्सेस
लब्स सर एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स फ्री में ला
होना अरे भाई क्या-क्या चीजें लेकर आए एक
साथ यह तो बताओ बहुत सारी चीजें चल रही है
ना पैरेलल अभी बहुत सारी चीजें आने वाली
है आपको पता है ए पन टेस्टिंग का कोर्स
आने वाला है हमारा लाइव ट्रेनिंग पेड होगा
बट बहुत अफोर्डेबल और बहुत ही शानदार और
इतना डीप होगा ना जो आप इमेजिन भी नहीं कर
सकते एंड यू विल बिकम मास्टर ऑफ ए
पेंटेस्टिंग इतना मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ
बोल सकता हूं वेट कीजिए उसके अनाउंसमेंट
का आप सभी लोग चलिए सो लेट इट ओपन
गाइ ओपन हो गया अकाउंट पे चलते हैं एंड आई
थिंक द अकाउंट इज विनर पीटर
सो लेट्स लॉग इन विथ
वन पीटर एंड प्रेस द लॉगइन
की लॉगइन हो गया यहां पर ईमेल आईडी यह है
ईमेल चेंज फंक्शनल में प्रॉब्लम है बट
इसमें क्या प्रॉब्लम है यह हम देखेंगे तो
हम क्या करते हैं यहां पर एक ईमेल डालते
हैं हैर @ hacker.com एंड इसको हम पहले
इंटरसेप्ट करते हैं देखते हैं क्या दिक्कत
है यहां पर हमने अपडेट ईमेल प क्लिक किया
यहां पर हमने इंटरसेप्ट ऑन किया फॉरवर्ड
किया एंड यहां पे जैसे ही हमने फॉरवर्ड
किया यहां पे आपको एक चीज देखने को मिलेगी
हमने जब इस रिक्वेस्ट को फॉरवर्ड किया
यहां पे तो आपको यह वाली जो रिक्वेस्ट है
इसको सेंड टू रिपीटर मैं कर देता हूं ये
हमें रिक्वेस्ट मिल चुकी है ठीक है सिंपल
सा फंडा है अब देखो क्या क्या क्या हो रहा
है यहां पे ठीक है अब यहां मैं इस
रिक्वेस्ट को पहले ड्रॉप कर देता हूं इसको
मैं ड्रॉप कर देता हूं बैक कर देता हूं
मैं आपको यहां पे ठीक है रिपीटर पे चलते
हैं यहां पे रिपीटर पे आ चुके हैं हम
रिक्वेस्ट एंड इधर रिस्पांस आपको दिख रही
है अब यहां पे बॉडी के अंदर में एक ईमेल
पैरामीटर है जहां पे हैर @ hacker.com
ईमेल जो हमने डाला था वो है और एक
सीएसआरएफ टोकन यहां पे डाला हुआ है देखो
अब तुम सीएसआरएफ टोकन जब तुम्हें कहीं
मिले तो तुम अलग-अलग तरीके से इसको बायपास
करने का ट्राई कर सकते हो क्या क्या तरीके
यूज कर सकते हो एक यह टोकन पहले हटा के
देख सकते हो यू कैन जस्ट रिमूव दिस टोकन
ये इसको हटा दिया अब देखते हैं इसको गो
करके सॉरी कुछ हो पाता है कि नहीं जैसे ही
आप गो प क्लिक करोगे यहां पे आ रहा है
मिसिंग पैरामीटर सीएसआरएफ यानी कि दिस इज
गेटिंग वैलिडेटेड तो यहां पे भाई ये चाहिए
तो सही पैरामीटर अब यहां पे तुम सेम लेंथ
का एक सीएसआरएफ टोकन डाल के यह भी ट्राई
कर सकते हो जैसे मैंने क्या किया मैं यहां
पे मैंने इसको कॉपी कर लिया सेम लेंथ का
सीएसआरएफ मैं डालता हूं यहां पे ओके मैं
यहां पे इसको पेस्ट कर देता हूं दिस वन
गेट पेस्टेड हियर एंड मैं इसको कंट्रोल सी
कर देता हूं मैं यहां पे वी कर देता हूं
एंड इसमें के कुछ चीजें मैं चेंज कर देता
हूं 1 दोती च पा इसके अंदर मैं एक दो
1 2 3 4 5 रैंडम कुछ स्ट्रिंग्स डाल देता
हूं यहां पे एंड यहां पे मैं इसको यहां
रिप्लेस कर देता हूं मैं इसको यहां पे
रिप्लेस करूंगा एंड नाउ आई विल प्रेस गो
जैसे ही मैं गो पे क्लिक करूंगा इट्स
सेइंग इनवैलिड सीएसआरएफ टोकन यानी ये भी
वैलिडेट हो रहा है कि ये टोकन वैलिड है या
नहीं है यानी कि आप इस मेथड का यूज यहां
फिर नहीं कर सकते हैं यानी कि ये वैलिडेशन
चेक हो रही है सीएसआरएफ टोकन की पहले हमने
क्या किया पूरा का पूरा पैरामीटर सीएसआरएफ
का टोकन हटा दिया नहीं ले रहा था क्यों की
टोकन वो पैरामीटर रिक्वायर्ड थी अब हमने
थोड़ा सा सेम लेंथ का टोकन डाला यहां पे
इनवैलिड सीएफ टोकन आ रहा है अब क्या
करेंगे
हम व्हाट वी विल डू हम पूरा का पूरा सीएस
आरएफ वाला जो पैरामीटर है इसको ही उड़ा
देते हैं पूरा का पूरा उड़ा देते हैं अब
गो पे क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग मिसिंग पैरामीटर सीएसआरएफ यानी
इसको पैरामीटर भाई अभी भी चाहिए यह
पैरामीटर तो चाहिए तो चलो यह तो हमने
क्लियर हो गया कि भाई इसके बिना यह चीज
नहीं हो पाएगी
दैट्ची करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो सीएसआरएफ
अ जो टोकन आपको यहां पे दिया हुआ है तो यू
कैन ट्राई टू बायपास इट बाय चेंजिंग द
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड क्या कर सकते हैं चेंजिंग
द रिक्वेस्ट मेथड तो रिक्वेस्ट मेथड कैसे
चेंज होती है अभी ये कौन सा रिक्वेस्ट है
पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट है इसको आपको चेंज करना
है गेट रिक्वेस्ट राइट क्लिक करेंगे एंड
यहां पे ऑप्शन आएगा चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड
जैसे ही चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड पे क्लिक
करेंगे इट विल चेंज टू गेट रिक्वेस्ट अब
जब गेट रिक्वेस्ट पे चेंज आपने किया यहां
पे सेम सीएसआरएफ टोकन है सीएसआरएफ टोकन
मान लो आपने कोई छेड़छाड़ नहीं की सेम ही
रखा है आपने कोई बात नहीं हम इस पे ट्राई
करेंगे देखने का क्या होता है गो पे क्लिक
करेंगे जैसे ही गो पे क्लिक करेंगे एंड
इट्स सेइंग 302 फाउंड इस बार कोई एरर नहीं
आई मिसिंग नहीं आया कोई इनवैलिड सीएसआर
टोकन नहीं आया बट क्या आया 302 फाउंड अब
यहां पे मैं फॉलो रीडायरेक्शन करता हूं
फॉलो रीडायरेक्शन जब करेंगे तो यहां पे
गाइस वी आर गेटिंग द रिस्पांस यर वी आर
गेटिंग द रिस्पांस हियर एंड इस रिस्पांस
के अंदर हमारी ईमेल आईडी जो है जो हमने
दिया हुआ था हैक @ hacker.com ये
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है ये देखो ये मेल आईडी
यहां पर रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है इट मींस
हमारा काम शायद हो चुका है एंड नाउ हम
इसको एग्जीक्यूट करके ट्राई करेंगे देखने
का एक सीएसआरएफ पीओ जनरेट
करके ठीक है चलिए तो सॉरी चलिए तो सीसर
पीसी जनरेट करते हैं राइट क्लिक करते हैं
इसको यहां एंगेजमेंट टूल्स पे जाते हैं
जनरेट सीएस आर पीओ करते हैं एंड यहां पे
अगर आप देखेंगे गाइस तो यहां पे नीचे की
तरफ आएंगे यहां पे इस वाले में तो
यर यू विल गेट
द ईमेल आईडी राइट वे द वेर इज द ईमेल
आईडी इ द ईमेल चेंज
फंक्शनल नो नो नोनो ये ये बेसिकली
रीडायरेक्ट के बाद वाली हमारी रिक्वेस्ट
है इसको मैं प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट प ले जाता
हूं ये प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट आ गई यहां पर
राइट क्लिक करते हैं इंगेजमेंट टूल्स
जनरेट सीएसआर पीओ ठीक है तो यहां पे हमारी
जो ईमेल आईडी है यह वाली है कौन सी है
हमारी ईमेल आईडी देख लो यहां पे व इ हैर @
hacker.com यहां पे हम ऑप्शन पे चलते हैं
इंक्लूड ऑटो सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट पे क्लिक कर
देते हैं इंक्लूड ऑटो सबमिट पे वो करके और
इसको हम यहां पे री जनरेट कर लेते हैं ठीक
है भैया हमने री जनरेट कर लिया चलो अब
इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं एटीएल कोड को कॉपी
करने के बाद हम चलते हैं एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर
पे
सॉरी
आई थिंक इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ है ऑन है इसको ऑफ कर
देते हैं एंड एक्सप्लो सर्वर को ओपन कर
लेते हैं एक्सट सर्वर को ओपन करने के बाद
यहां बॉडी में हम अपना सीएसआरएफ पीसी यहां
एंटर कर देते हैं एंड यहां पर हमारा यह
वाली जो अटैकर की ईमेल आईडी है व यहां पर
मैं स्टोर पर क्लिक कर देता
हूं स्टोर पर क्लिक करने के बाद मैं यहां
प डिलीवर एक्सप्लोइट टू विक्टिम पर क्लिक
करता हूं ी व्ट इ
हैपनिंग या ी
ट एंड हमने यह किया
बट कुछ हुआ नहीं आई थिंक ऑटो सबमिट
स्क्रिप्ट हमने लगा दिया था यहां पर इसकी
वजह से हुआ क्या
लेट्स लेट्स रिमूव द इंक्लूड ऑटो सबमिट
एंड यहां री जनरेट करते हैं कॉपी करते हैं
एंड यहां पर एंटर करते हैं अब अगेन स्टोर
करते
हैं ओके नाउ लेट्स डिलीवर विक्टिम द
एक्सप्लोइट एंड वी डिलीवर्ड इट हियर
बट कुछ मिला नहीं हमें यहां
से ओके क्यों नहीं मिला हमें यहां पर कुछ
रिजल्ट में लेट्स चेक इ देर एनीथिंग दैट
वी आर
डूइंग
इनकरेक्ट सो गेट रिक्वेस्ट हमने किया हमने
फॉलो डायरेक्शन फॉलो किया यहां पे सो
लेट्स सी क्या दिक्कत आ रही है
अ यू कैन नॉट रजिस्टर एन ईमेल एड्रेस दैट
इज ऑलरेडी टेकन बाय अनदर यूजर इफ यू चेंज
योर ईमेल एड वाइल एक्सप्लोइट यू मेक
डिफरेंट ईमेल द फाइल एक्सप्लॉयड डिलीवर टू
फम ठीक है एक कोई दूसरा ईमेल आईडी चेंज
देख लेते हैं शायद ये ईमेल आईडी कहीं यूज़
हो रही हो मे भी हैर @ hacker.com तो मैं
क्या करता हूं हैर
9958 @ hacker.com यह वाली चीज करता हूं
मैं यहां पे एंड यहां पे मैं री जनरेट
करता हूं यहां मैं कॉपी कर लेता
हूं एंड लेट्स डू वंस अगेन मैं यहां पे
इसको पेस्ट कर देता हूं स्टोर करता हूं
मैं यहां
पे एंड नाउ डिलीवर एक्सप्लोइट टू
विक्टिम लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग ओके सो हम कर तो रहे हैं सब कुछ
सही लेकिन आई थिंक देयर इज सम इश्यूज विथ
फफ बिकॉज लेट्स चेक द य य पे हिंट में
सॉरी
ओके यहां पे सेम चीज है यहां पे सेम चीज
दे आर डूइंग नथिंग नथिंग कोई डिफरेंट चीज
नहीं हो रही है
राइट सो वी आर डूइंग करेक्ट बट यहां पे आई
थिंक फफ ब्राउजर का इशू है तो हम एक बार
ना कम में चलते हैं एक बार कम में सेम काम
करते हैं कम में हम वेब सिक्योरिटी ओपन कर
लेट्स सी इ समथिंग इ
हैपनिंग
ओके लेट्स गो टू सीएसआर
लपस लेट्स गो टू द
लब्स रिक्वेस्ट मेथड वाली पेज चलते
हैं लब को एक्सेस कर लेते हैं
यहां मैं क्लोज कर देता
हूं ओके अकाउंट प चलते हैं इसको लॉगइन कर
लेते
हैं विनर एंड यहां पे पीटर यहां लॉगइन पे
क्लिक कर देते हैं firefox.exe
में लॉग इन किया समझ में आ रहा है
firefox.exe
इंटरसेप्ट इज ऑन जस्ट अपडेटिंग ईमेल आईडी
एंड यहां पे फॉरवर्ड करता हूं मैं यह वाली
आ आ चुकी है हमारे पास मैं इसको राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड अ यहां पे सिंपल मैं क्या
करता हूं राइट क्लिक करता हूं चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड पे क्लिक कर देता हूं जैसे
ही चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड पे क्लिक किया
यहां पे इन ये वाली चीज आ चुकी है यहां पे
एलयूर @ hacker.com नाउ व्हाट आई एम गोइंग
टू डू राइट क्लिक एंड च एंगेजमेंट टूल्स
जनरेट सीएसआर पीओ एंड यहां पे मैं ऑप्शन
में चलो ऑटो सबमिट नहीं करते यहां पे कॉपी
कर लेते एटीएमएल को एंड यहां पर इस
रिक्वेस्ट को ड्रॉप कर देते हैं लेट्स गो
टू दिस वन लेट्स गो टू एक्सप्लोइट
सर्वर चलिए एक्सप्लो सवर प चलते हैं लेट्स
सी इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं यहां पे
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर प चलते हैं एक्सप्लोइट
सर्वर पे आ चुके हैं हम यहां पे बॉडी में
जो है वो डाल देते हैं यहां पे एंड एवल
यूजर वाली स्टोर कर स्टोर प क्लिक कर देते
हैं देन यहां पर हम कर देते हैं डिलीवर
एक्सप्लोइट टू विक्टिम एंड जैसे ही हम इस
पर क्लिक करेंगे हमारा लैब सॉल्व हो जाना
चाहिए क्योंकि firefox.exe
[संगीत]
यहां पर रिपीटर टैब में करके हमने यहां पर
किया था एवल यूजर वाली वो चीज हमारी काम
कर गई थी बेसिकली यहां पर राइट क्लिक करके
यहां पर एंगेजमेंट टूल जनरेट सार पीसी
हमने किया हुआ था एंड ऑटो सबमिट आप इनेबल
कर दो अगर आपको करना है तो री जनरेट कर दो
कॉपी कर लो एचटीएमएल को एंड यहां पर पेस्ट
करके आप डाल दो ठीक है तो यह काम कर जाएगी
ठीक है यह सेम प्रोसेस है आपको कुछ भी
उल्टा पुल्टा नहीं करना है सेम चीज ठीक
है ओके हमने यह चेंज कर लिया डिलीवर
एक्सप्लोइट टू
विक्टिम
ओके ईमेल आईडी एक बार चेंज कर लेते हैं
हैकर को हम रख देते हैं एविल हैकर एविल वन
हैर एलव हैकर @ hacker.com अब इसको स्टोर
कर लेते
हैं नाउ लेट्स डिलीवर द एक्सप्लोर टू
विक्टिम एंड ट्स इट जैसे ही हमने ये काम
किया हमने ईमेल आईडी चेंज की यहां पे
थोड़ा सा क्योंकि हमने पहले य ईमेल आईडी
यूज कर ली थी यहां पे आ रहा है
कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्वड लैब सो दिस वे वी
सॉल्व दिस लैब ऑफ सीएसआरएफ एंड वी गॉट द
सॉल्व लैब अ पॉप अप हमने आपने आपने ये
सॉल्व कर लिया सिंपल सा फंडा है तो इस
तरीके से सीएसआरए वनल बिटीज को फाइंड की
जाती है अब यहां पे सीएसआरए वन बिटीज के
बहुत डिफरेंट डिफरेंट टाइप्स के अलग-अलग
तरीके के टेक्निक्स होते हैं उनको बायपास
करने के जो मैंने आपको अभी बताया अब देखो
सीएसआरएफ टोकेंस कहां-कहां आपको मिल सकते
हैं सीएसआरएफ टोकेंस आपको हेडर में मिल
सकते हैं आपको बॉडी के बॉडी के अंदर में
मिल सकता है ठीक है ना वहां पे भी आपको
मिल सकता है अ तो आपको करना है जहां पर भी
आपको सीएसआरएफ टोकन ऐसा मिल रहा है यू कैन
ट्राई टू
सरकमवेंट्स क्लोज दिस फ्रॉम यर एंड कम टू
र ठीक
है ओके डिस्क्रिप्शन प आते हैं एवरीवन गट
इट समझ में आ रहा है आपको प्लीज लेट मी नो
समझ में आ रहा है
आपको ओके सर एक रिक्वेस्ट है सर आपका
कोर्स जो आप लंच करोगे उसका प्राइस पॉकेट
फ्रेंडली रखना प्लीज सर बिकॉज मैं और भी
जगह बात किया था तो उनका कोर्स 50000 का
बता दिया अब मैं कहां से लाऊ 500 अरे
पुलकित ब्रदर पहली बात तो जितने भी
कोर्सेस हमारे होते हैं आपको ऑलरेडी पता
होना चाहिए या सब लोग को पता होगा कि वी
ट्राई टू कीप इट मोस्ट पॉकेट फ्रेंडली एंड
मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल ये हमारा वैसे भी मोटो भी
है एंड बाकी सभी लोगों से काफी कम होता है
जितने भी कोर्सेस हैं अभी तक के मैं आपको
गारंटी के साथ बोल सकता हूं तो टेंशन मत
लो बहुत ही लेसर एंड अफोर्डेबल प्राइसिंग
रहेगी जो भी कोर्सेस आए ठीक
है चलो यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा अब
सी सार वटी तो आप फाइंड कर ही लोगे मेरे
ख्याल से ज्यादा आपको टेंशन नहीं होनी
चाहिए ज्यादा आपको दिक्कत नहीं होनी चाहिए
राइट और लाइक लाइक ठोका नहीं यार आप लोगों
ने ये गलत बात है लाइक नहीं ठोकते
या
ए पेन टेस्टिंग की कोर्स आएगी यार कोर्स
कोर्स आएगी ठीक है अब मैं आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं सीएसआरएफ ऑल लैब्स पे
आप आ जाइएगा एंड इसके जो भी लैब्स है ना
यहां पे आप उसको ट्राई कीजिएगा सॉल्व करने
का ठीक है मैं यहां पे इसको क्लोज करके
इंटरसेप्ट इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ ही है यहां पे
बहुत सारे लैब्स है बहुत सारे तो नहीं है
अ बट इतने लैब्स है 1 दोती 4 पा छ छह
लैब्स है जहां पे हमने दो किए अभी एक और
लैब है जैसे टोकन बंग प्रेजेंट के बेसिस
पे कैसे आपको सारे फाइंड करना है नॉट टाइट
टू यूजर सेशन इस पे कैसे आपको करना है नॉट
इज टाइट टू ए नॉन सेशन को कि इस पे कैसे
आपको फाइंड करना है एंड वेर टोकन इज
डुप्लीकेटेड इन कुकी इसको आपको कैसे सॉल्व
करना है तो ये ट्राई आउट कीजिएगा इसके
लैब्स को सॉल्व कर लीजिएगा इट विल बी वेरी
वेरी वेरी मच हेल्पफुल ठीक है चलिए अब हम
रियल अगर किसी टारगेट पे ये ट्राई करना
चाहे तो वो भी हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं किसी
भी रियल टारगेट को पकड़ सकते हैं ठीक है
जहां पे कोई भी एक प्रोफाइल ऑप्शन वहां पे
जहां पे प्रोफाइलिंग ऑप्शन हो वहां पे हम
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं इस चीज को करने का
तो एक काम करते हैं लेट्स गो
टू सम वेबसाइट जैसे कि मैं चलता
हूं थैंक यू थैंक यू फैक्ट
बाय सब बब शूट प्रो की एक्सेस की नहीं मिल
रही है यह आपको ऑलरेडी बताया गया ग्रुप प
प्लीज आप जाके चेक आउट कीजिए वेबसाइट वाले
प ठीक है कोई बात नहीं कोई बात
नहीं मैं सेंड कर दूंगा बब शूट वाली टेंशन
मत लो ओके चलो यहां पर आते हैं यहां पर हम
यहां पर एक कोई भी एक वेबसाइट को पकड़
लेते हैं
कोई भी एक वेबसाइट को पकड़ लेते हैं जैसे
कि लेट्स सपोज लेटस सी न थ लेस रिमूव द
दिस वन थ
एंड
ओके लेट्स ओपन दिस वन कोई और कोई कोई
वेबसाइट बताओ ना जिस हम टारगेट जिसको
टारगेट लेकर चले एवन प्लीज
निशांत हेलो निशांत कैसे हो कैसे हो कैसे
हो ब्रदर कैसे हो बिल्कुल सही ना कोई
वेबसाइट बताओ टारगेट के लिए हम लेते हैं
जिसको इफ यू वांट जहां पर लॉगिन फंक्शनल
हो जहां पर अकाउंट अपडेशन फंक्शनल हो इस
टाइप की कुछ फंक्शनल हो व वाली बताना ठीक
है सो प्लीज प्लीज लेट म बताइए
मुझे नहीं कोई बहुत ज्यादा पॉपुलर वेबसाइट
मत बताओ टोमेटो वगैरह प आपको जल्दी
मिलेंगी नहीं मेरे ख्याल
से बताइए कोई और वेबसाइट बताइए कोई दूसरी
वेबसाइट बताइए कोई जेनरिक वेबसाइट बताइए
कोई छोटी
मोटी नहीं आप जेनरिक वेबसाइट तो बता ही
नहीं रहे आप
लोग जिनका ऑलरेडी आप ये ऐसे वेबसाइट है
जिनकी बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम चलती है ऑलरेडी
एंड ऑलरेडी ये वरे बिलिटी रिसर्चस ने
ट्राई आउट कर लिया होगा कोई फायदा नहीं
है ओके रेड बबल व्हाट इज दिस रेड बबल
लेट्स
सी ओके रेड बबल प चलते हैं आई डोंट नो व्ट
इज दिस सो लेट्स गो हियर हां जी तो ये एक
वेबसाइट है चलो बढ़िया है रेड बबल वेबसाइट
है यूएस की कोई की वेबसाइट है तो यह चलो
यह अच्छी अच्छी है यह टारगेट अच्छी है
इसमें कुछ लॉगइन फंक्शन टी वगैरह भी है तो
चलिए हम यहां पर साइन अप कर लेते
हैं आर्टिस्ट साइन अप या कस्टमर साइन अप
तो कस्टमर साइन अप करते हैं एंड यहां पर
हम कर देते हैं टम
मेल लेट्स
ओपन ईमेल आईडी यूज कर लेते हैं हम यहां पर
टेंपररी ईमेल आईडी
हमारी लेट्स कॉपी द ईमेल
आईडी के लेट्स प्रोवाइड ईमेल आईडी लेट्स
प्रोवाइड यूजर नेम सो इट्स
इट
इट्स लाइक मिस्टर
परफेक्ट
से लेट्स गिव इट
पासवर्ड सो हम यहां पर साइन अप कर रहे हैं
एंड आई होप कि साइन अप हो जाना चाहिए
ईमेल आईडी
से ओके सो साइन अप हमने कर लिया है
कंप्लीट एंड लेट्स सी इफ वी गट सम ईमेल ऑन
साइन अप कुछ हमें ईमेल मिला है क्या कोई
नो वी डिड नट गेट एनी ईमेल सो परफेक्ट
फाइन कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो हमने एक यहां
पर अकाउंट बनाया है यह एक अटैकर का अकाउंट
है चलो तो हम यहां पर थोड़ा मेंशन कर देते
हैं अकाउंट वन इसको मैं थोड़ा सा बड़ा कर
देता हूं आपको दिखाने के लिए जो है यह
अटैक का अकाउंट है एंड यहां पर हमने यूजर
नेम जो यूज किया है वो यूज किया है मिस्टर
परफेक्ट
007 यहां पर हमने एक पासवर्ड यूज किया है
एंड यहां पर हमने ईमेल आईडी यूज की है दैट
ईमेल आईडी इज दिस वन ठीक है अब यहां पे हम
अकाउंट टू बनाते हैं अकाउंट टू जो कि एक
विक्टिम का अकाउंट होगा ठीक है इसका यूजर
नेम यूजर नेम हम यहां पर कुछ डाल देंगे बट
फिलहाल के लिए अभी रहने देते हैं यहां पर
हमने एक अकाउंट बना बना लिया है अब हम
क्रम पर चलते हैं एंड यहां पर रेड बबल
टाइप करते हैं एंटर करते हैं एंड लेट्स
ओपन
इट लेट्स गो
हियर ओके एंड बप शूट यहां पे इनेबल है
डिसेबल कर देते हैं इसको कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है लेट डिसेबल
इट ठीक है लेट लट यहां पे चलते हैं यहां
पे हम करते साइन
अप ओके टेंप मेल यहां पर भी टेंप मेल ओपन
करके यहां पर एक साइन अप कर लेते हैं
कस्टमर साइन अप करते हैं ईमेल आईडी ले
लेते यूजर नेम यहां पर डाल देते हैं यहां
डाल देते हैं
मिस्टर
परफेक्ट विक्टिम मिस्टर परफेक्ट विक्टिम
डाल देते हैं यहां पे मिस्टर परफेक्ट
विक्टिम पासवर्ड डाल देते
हैं चलिए हमने पासवर्ड ड एंड यहां पे हमने
ईमेल आईडी यूज कर लिया सो लेट्स गिव इट
ईमेल आईडी ठीक है तो यहां पे यहां हमने
मिस्टर परफेक्ट विक्टिम जो है यह वाली
डिटेल्स यहां पर डाल देते हैं जो विक्टिम
का है मिस्टर परफेक्ट विक्टिम ईमेल जो है
वो यह वाली है
सॉरी ईमेल जो है हमने जो यूज किया वो यह
वाली ईमेल यूज की है यहां पे एंड पासवर्ड
जो है वो हमने सेम पासवर्ड यूज किया है जो
ऊपर में यूज किया था
ठीक है सो यर लेट्स साइन
अप ओके इट्स
लोडिंग चलिए तो यहां पर भी साइन अप हो
चुका है तो यह हमारा विक्टिम का अकाउंट है
अब मैं विक्टिम के अकाउंट के अकाउंट
सेटिंग में चलता हूं यहां पे मतलब अकाउंट
के डिटेल्स पे चलता हूं यहां पे जब अकाउंट
के डिटेल्स पे आऊंगा तो यहां पे मिस्टर
परफेक्ट विक्टिम आ रहा है इ देर ईमेल चेंज
फंक्शनल कहीं कुछ मुझे दिख नहीं रही है
यार अकाउंट सेटिंग में चलते
हैं हां जी तो अकाउंट सेटिंग में आ चुके
यहां पे एंड यहां पे आपके पास डिटेल्स है
सारी ठीक है अच्छी बात है बहुत सारी
डिटेल्स है ग्रेट एंड यहां पे ईमेल एड्रेस
जो है आपका यहां पर दिख रहा है हिस ऐसे
कुछ करके ईमेल आईडी ये वाली आ रही है आपकी
तो दिस वन इज द मम ईमेल अकाउंट अब हम आते
हैं अटैकर वाली अटैकर वाली पेज पे यहां पर
आ जाते हैं मिस्टर परफेक्ट 107
पे लेट्स सी नाउ
हियर यहां पर हम इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं
बढ़िया लेट्स गो टू द अकाउंट
सेटिंग नाउ हेयर वी आर ऑन अकाउंट सेटिंग
एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू चेंज समथिंग ईमेल
एड्रेस तो चेंज का ऑप्शन ही नहीं आ रहा
यहां पर यू कैन नॉट चेंज द ईमेल एड्रेस
ट्स फाइन कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कुछ और चेंज
करके देख सकते हैं
चेंज डैशबोर्ड प क्या
है ओके डैशबोर्ड पर कुछ भी नहीं है
पासवर्ड चेंज करने का ऑप्शन आ रहा है
क्या चेंज पासवर्ड पर चलते हैं ओके सो
करंट पासवर्ड न्यू पासवर्ड दो चीजें यहां
पर आ रही है करंट पासवर्ड एंड न्यू
पासवर्ड तो दो चीजें यहां पर आपको चेंज
करने का ऑप्शन यहां पर आ रहा है सो वाई
लेट्स सी लेट्स सी इफ वी कैन डू समथिंग
राइट तो हम यहां पे करंट पासवर्ड डाल रहे
हैं एंड न्यू पासवर्ड यहां पे चेंज करने
का डाल रहे हैं एंड इसमें हम ट्राई करेंगे
विक्टिम के पासवर्ड को चेंज करने का वी
विल ट्राई टू चेंज द विक्टिम पासवर्ड राइट
सो लेट्स डू इट ओके बायो चेंज का भी है
बहुत कुछ है यहां पे वी कैन डू एनीथिंग
चलो यहां फर्स्ट नेम है यहां
पे ओके फर्स्ट नेम में यहां पे कौन सा य
हमारा मिस्टर परफेक्ट 107 ठीक है तो
फर्स्ट नेम में डाल देते हैं यहां पे
हैकर ओके हैकर सिंक हैकर सिंक हमने डाल
दिया यह दो चीज हमने यहां पर डाली यहां पे
ठीक है एंड नाउ वी विल जस्ट वल जस्ट ट्राई
टू सेव द चेंजेज सो लेट्स इंटरसेप्ट ऑन
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर देते हैं यहां पे एंड
यहां पर सेव चेंजेज पर क्लिक करते हैं
लेट्स इंटरसेप्ट इट फॉरवर्ड करते हैं यहां
पे एंड दिस वन वन व्हाट इज दिस वन
अ फॉरवर्ड ओके अकाउंट सेटिंग प्रोफाइल
redbubble.com यहां पे आ चुका है यहां पे
नाउ इट्स के बॉडी में चलते हैं यहां पे
एंड आई थिंक देयर शुड बी अ डिस्प्ले यहां
पे नेम आना चाहिए अ हैकर सिं ये रहा हैकर
सिं ये वाली नेम हम चेंज करें हैकर सिं
वाली तो व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू राइट
क्लिक डू इ इंगेजमेंट टूल्स पे चलते हैं
यहां पे जनरेट सीएसआरएफ पीओ ठीक है ये
हमने कर दिया यहां पे नाउ व्हाट आई एम
गोइंग टू डू हम यह जो सीएसआरएफ जनरेट कर
रहे हैं इसमें हमने क्या किया है जो नेम
हमने डाला हुआ है वोह क्या डाला हुआ है
हैकर सिं ठीक है ये आप देख सकते हो यहां
पे हैकर और सिं ये चीज डाली हुई है अब अगर
यह विक्टिम के अकाउंट में यह चेंज आ जाता
है बाय चांस देन देयर इज अ सीएसआरएफ ठीक
है तो सिंपल सा हम यहां पे ऑप्शन पे चलते
हैं इंक्लूड ऑटो सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट कर देते
हैं री जनरेट कर देते हैं एटीएमएल को एंड
यहां पे एटीए को हम यहां पे कॉपी कर लेते
हैं एटील कॉपी कर लिया अब हम एक एटीएल पेज
यहां प क्रिएट कर लेते हैं सिंपल सा फंडा
है
सो लेट्स क्रिएट
इट ओके लेट्स क्रिएट द एटीएमएल
एंड दिस वन सेम कंट्रोल
एस रेड बबल सी एस सीआरए
वाले किसके मिस्टर परफेक्ट 07 हमारा
विक्टिम अकाउंट कौन सा है भैया हमारा
विक्टिम अकाउंट जो है वो है मिस मिस्टर
परफेक्ट विक्टिम ठीक है तो मैं इस
रिक्वेस्ट को पहले ड्रॉप कर देता हूं
लेट्स ड्रॉप दिस रिक्वेस्ट ट गो टू द
इंटरसेप्ट ड्रॉप मतलब मुझे अभी ये
रिक्वेस्ट की जरूरत नहीं है ड्रॉप कर दिया
बैक कर लेते
हैं ओके आई थिंक इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ करना
पड़ेगा मुझे इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं
एंड दैट इट खत्म यहां पे अब मैं चलता हूं
विक्टिम वाले अकाउंट पे एंड लेट्स ट्राई
आउट हियर सो विक्टिम अकाउंट प यहां पे हम
आ चुके हैं एंड वी आर गोइंग टू ओपन अभी
यहां देखो विक्टिम अकाउंट प मैं रिड करता
हूं इस पेज को फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम अभी
यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं होगा शायद मेरे ख्याल
से लेट्स सी ये विक्टिम का अकाउंट है ठीक
है रीलोड रीलोड हो रहा है भाई हो जाने दो
एक बार रिड
कंप्लीट चलो भाई फिर से रिड कर देते हैं
ओके रीलोड हो चुका है यहां पर
स्टिल गोल गोल घूम ही रही है अरे रुक जा
भाई रीलोड किया हमने यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं
आ रहा फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम कुछ भी नहीं आ
रहा यहां प पॉपलेट नहीं हुआ कुछ भी सो ट्स
इट अब हम यहां पे क्या करते हैं इस वाले
सीएसआरएफ जो पेलोड है इसको हम ब्राउजर में
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं क्योंकि ओबवियसली यह
हमारा क्रम ही है तो जस्ट ये ऑटोमेटिक
एग्जीक्यूट होगा जैसे ही हमने एग्जीक्यूट
किया ना गाइस यह आ रहा है यहां पर लॉगिन
का अब यहां पर य बोल रहा है लॉगइन कीजिए
यहां पे हमने ऑलरेडी लॉगइन कर रखा था बस
जैसे ही हमने किया यहां पे लॉगइन का मांग
रहा है यहां पे ये आपसे लॉगइन के लिए बोल
रहा है तो चलिए लॉगइन कर लेते हैं एक बार
लेट्स लॉगइन तो हमारा लॉगिन क्या था
विक्टिम का मिस्टर परफेक्ट
विक्टिम एंड पासवर्ड
में पासवर्ड डाल देते हैं एंड जस्ट ट्राइम
टू लॉग इन नाउ लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग
वी आर लॉगइन एंड लॉग इन के बाद देखेंगे
कुछ चेंज हुआ है कि नहीं हुआ अगर कुछ चेंज
हुआ होगा तो सीएसआरएफ है अदर वाइज
सीएसआरएफ नहीं है सिंपल सो गो टू अकाउंट
सेटिंग एंड इडिट प्रोफाइल प्रोफाइल
प्रोफाइल एंड आई डोंट थिंक सो सो नो देयर
इज नो सीएसआरएफ कोई यहां पे सीएसआरएफ यहां
पे नहीं है बट अब यहां पे सीएसआरएफ नहीं
है गाइस इसका मतलब ये नहीं है कि यहां
सीएसआरएफ हो ही नहीं सकती या एकदम से
बिल्कुल नहीं होगी अब देखो मैंने यहां पे
क्या किया ये वाली चीज थी ये वाली सेम चीज
थी मैं यहां पे राइट क्लिक करता हूं इसको
रिपीटर को सेंड कर देता हूं इसको क्लोज कर
देता हूं और यहां पे चलता हूं यहां रिपीटर
पे आते हैं ये सेम आपका रिक्वेस्ट था ठीक
है ये एक पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट है अकाउंट से
प्रोफाइल का यहां जब नीचे की तरफ आप
आओगे नीचे की तरफ यहां पे आओगे यहां पे
नीचे की तरफ तो यह हैकर सिंग वाली चीज हो
रही थी अब यहां पे सीएसआरएफ सर्च करो
सीएसआरएफ एंड इ यू आर गेटिंग एनीथिंग नो
यू आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग यू आर नॉट
गेटिंग एनीथिंग हमें कोई भी चीज नहीं मिल
रही है यहां पे अब मैं यहां पे अगर सेम
चीज मैं अगर यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देता
हूं व्हाट इज हैपनिंग लेट्स सी 302 फाउंड
आ रहा है यहां पे परफेक्ट चलिए फॉलो
डायरेक्शन रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो करते हैं यहां
पे एंड 200 ओके आ रहा है यहां पे एंड यहां
पे हम क्या कर देते हैं हैकर सिं तो
हैकर एंड यहां हैकर आ चुका सिं एंड हैकर
सिं ये चीज आ रही है फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम
ठीक है अब मैं इसको बैक करता हूं प्रीवियस
रिक्वेस्ट पे चलता हूं यहां पे अब यहां पे
हमें ट्राई करना है कि हम कुछ कर सकते हैं
क्या कुछ लाइक बायपास करने का ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं क्या इफ यू कैन ट्राई आउट देन
दैट विल बी ग्रेट ठीक है तो हम यहां पे
लॉगइन ऑलरेडी हैं आ चुके हैं हम अपने
विक्टिम अकाउंट में ऑलरेडी लॉगइन हो चुके
हैं अब इसमें थोड़ा सा मैनिपुलेशन करने की
कोशिश करते हैं ठीक है चलिए पहले तो ये
पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट है अकाउंट सेटिंग
प्रोफाइल देर इजन ओपन आईडी टोकन ठीक
है एंड दिस
टोकन इज किस टाइप का टोकन है मैं एक बार
देख लेता
हूं दे नो लाइक इनकोडेड टोकन वगैरह को भी
आपको ट्राई देखना है ओके आरबी सेशन
कुकी कंसेंट
ओके यहां पर डबल इक्वल्स एक बार सर्च करते
हैं बहुत सारे बेस 64 इनकोडिंग भी होते
हैं बहुत जगह पर तो व सर्च कर लिया हमने
वो चीज नहीं है य पर एंड लेटस ट्राई टू
सरकमवेंटेड
एक बार वीडियो देखोगे हो
जाएगा हेलो सर थैंक यू फॉर र ब बांटी फ्री
कैप्सूल कोर्स यू आर वेलकम
ब्रदर यू आर मोस्ट
वेलकम चलिए अब यहां पे हम पोस्ट को गेट
में चेंज करते हैं एक बार वो वाली ट्राई
करते हैं जो हमने ट्राई किया था तो राइट
क्लिक करते हैं यहां पे एंड चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड ये चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड कर
लिया ये गेट रिक्वेस्ट में आ चुका है यहां
पे एंड नाउ नाउ नाउ नाउ नाउ नाउ ट्स इट
लेट्स क्लिक ऑन द
गो सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग ओ डायरेक्ट यहां
पे ओके आ रहा है चलो एक बार ट्राई आउट कर
लेते हैं राइट क्लिक करते हैं एंगेजमेंट
टूल जनरेट सीएसआर पीओ एंड नाउ हियर वी हैव
जेनरेटेड द सीएसआर पीसी नाउ लेट्स कॉपी
दिस पीसी एक बार यह वाली गेट वाली एक बार
कॉपी कर लेते हैं पीसी जो हमारी है कॉपी
कर लिया हमने एंड यहां पे हमारा जो ये
एचटीएमएल फाइल है रेड बबल वाली इसको एडिट
कर देते हैं एडिट विथ नोटपैड लेट्स पेस्ट
इन पेस्ट इन यर जो गेट वाली हमारी
सीएसआरएफ थी वो हमने यहां पर पेस्ट इन कर
दिया है सेव कर देते हैं लेट्स ओपन इट
लेट्स ओपन इट एंड नाउ क्योंकि ने ऑटो
सबमिट स्क्रिप्ट यहां पे नहीं इंक्लूड
किया है तो सबमिट रिक्वेस्ट प आपको क्लिक
करना पड़ेगा ठीक है तो मैं यहां प सबमिट
रिक्वेस्ट पर क्लिक करता हूं एंड लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग या इस बार लॉग आउट तो नहीं हुआ बट
इट नट गेट लगड आउट
बट आई थिंक चेंज तो नहीं हुआ है बट ये लॉग
आउट भी नहीं हुआ है चलो कुछ तो कुछ तो वो
हुआ पहले तो लॉग आउट हो गया था हमारा सो
या ओके इफ वी
आर इफ वी आर चेंजिंग हियर मैनुअली हैकर
सिंग व्हाट इज हैपनिंग इज इट रिटेनिंग द
यूजर नेम एंड फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम यस तो
रिटेन हो रहा है ये ठीक है तो यहां पे
हमारा चेंज यहां पे अपडेट नहीं हो पा रहा
है हमने गेट वाला भी किया हमने सर कवट
करके भी ट्राई किया तो यह सीएसआरएफ
वल्नरेबल नहीं है मतलब कहने का सेंस यह है
कि आपको हर एक वेबसाइट पे कुछ इस तरीके से
ही ट्राई आउट करना है जो भी चेंज फंक्शन
लिटी है उसको ट्राई आउट कर देना है ठीक है
चेंज पासवर्ड जो है उसको भी आप ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हो चेंज ईमेल आईडी को कर सकते हो
पेमेंट मेथड्स को जैसे ये पेमेंट डिटेल्स
है ठीक है ये पेमेंट डिटेल्स प आ जाते हैं
यहां पे जैसे आप देख सकते हो यहां
पे अकाउंट पेमेंट डिटेल्स में आप आओगे तो
यहां पे बहुत सारी पेमेंट डिटेल्स है बहुत
सारी चीजें यहां पे वो आप कर सकते हो चेंज
पासवर्ड पे आओगे आप चेंज पासवर्ड कर सकते
हो जो भी आपकी मर्जी है वो कर सकते हो ठीक
है मैं यहां पे चेंज पासवर्ड पे आ जाता
हूं तो आप करंट पासवर्ड न्यू पासवर्ड
डालिए इसको आप इंटरसेप्ट कीजिए एंड ट्राई
आउट कीजिए अगर सेम चीज आप एग्जीक्यूट करा
पा रहे हैं विक्टिम के अकाउंट पे तो चेंज
पासवर्ड वाले भी एक बार हम ट्राई आउट कर
लेते हैं ठीक है सो करंट पासवर्ड मैं डाल
देता
हूं
एंड न्यू पासवर्ड मैं डाल देता हूं न्यू
पासवर्ड
इज न्यू पासवर्ड मैंने डाला है यह
[संगीत]
वाला
न्यू रेट पासवर्ड न्यू रेट पासवर्ड यह
मैंने पासवर्ड डाला है न्यू पासवर्ड एंड
मैं इसको इंटरसेप्ट करूंगा ठीक
है लेट गो टू द प्रॉक्सी इंटरसेप्ट ऑन
लेट्स गो हियर चेंज पासवर्ड एंड लेट्स
इंटरसेप्ट फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड कर
देते हैं यह रही रेड बाउल अकाउंट पासवर्ड
य आ चुका है य पासवर्ड वाली एंड यहां पर
जब अब देखो यहां पर जब मैंने यह चेंज
पासवर्ड करा है तो आपको कुछ चीज बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग मिली है ठीक है क्या मिली है
मैं आपको बताता हूं सेंड टू रिपीटर पहले
इसको मैं सेंड कर देता हूं यहां पर
एक ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन मिला है हमें यह वाली
ऑथेंटिसिटी
टोकन यह हमें मिली है यूजर अकाउंट यहां पर
पासवर्ड आया यहां पे जो न्यू पासवर्ड है
वो न्यू पासवर्ड आ गया एंड न्यू पासवर्ड
में हमने ए कैपिटल रखा है
क्या ओके एन को कैपिटल रखा है हमने शायद
हा जी हमने को कैपिटल न्यू ट पासवर्ड ठीक
है है तो ये हमने कर दिया अब अब हम क्या
करते हैं इसको ट्राई आउट करते हैं
एग्जीक्यूट करने का तो राइट क्लिक करते
हैं यहां पे एंगेजमेंट टूल्स पे जाते हैं
जनरेट सीएसआरएफ पीओ पे जाते हैं बट उसके
पहले मैंने रिपीटर को भेजा हुआ है ना इसको
मैं ड्रॉप कर देता हूं लेट्स ड्रॉप दिस
थिंग क्यों ड्रॉप करना है मैं आपको बताता
हूं रिपीटर प चलते हैं यहां पे अब यहां पे
रिपीटर वाले सेक्शन में यहां पे आते हैं
एंड लेट्स डू वन थिंग इज देरनी सीएसआरएफ
सीएसआरएफ टोकन मैचिंग सीएसआरएफ कीवर्ड
नहीं ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन है तो हम क्या
करेंगे ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन को यहां पे
ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन जो है ना यहां पे इसको
पूरा रिमूव कर देते
हैं लेट्स रिमूव दिस ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन
लेट्स रिमूव दिस टोकन
दैट्ची है एक बार इस पे ट्राई आउट कर लेते
हैं राइट क्लिक करते हैं एंगेजमेंट टूल पे
चलते हैं जनरेट सीओ आरफ पीओ पे करते हैं
[संगीत]
एंड ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन आई थिंक हट चुकी है
बिल्कुल सही यहां पर हमने कॉपी किया एंड
अब जो है रेड वाली रेड बबल वाली जो है इसी
पे एडिट कर देते हैं यहां मैंने इसको
रिमूव करके आने वाली जो पीसी है उसको डाल
दिया यह सेम है ना यार कौन सी है
ये
अ
ओके ओके सेम है तो हमने इसको सेव कर दिया
अब इसको मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड लेट्स
सबमिट द रिक्वेस्ट लेट्स सी व्ट इ
हैपनिंग ओके लॉग आउट हो चुका है यह
विक्टिम के अकाउंट नाउ व्हाट आई एम ट्राइट
डू आई एम ट्रांग टू लॉग इन टू विक्टिम
अकाउंट विथ द अपडेटेड पासवर्ड जो हमने
पासवर्ड चेंज किया था उससे हम लॉगिन करने
की कोशिश करेंगे आई डोंट नो इफ इट इ इफ इट
विल
वर्क ओके सो विक्टिम का यह वाला यूजर नेम
था मिस्टर परफेक्ट विक्टिम एंड पासवर्ड जो
नया था न्यू रेट पासवर्ड इससे लॉगइन करने
का ट्राई करते हैं अगर ये लॉगइन हो गया तो
सीएसआर है नहीं तो नहीं है ठीक है लेट्स
ट्राई नहीं नहीं हो रहा सो इट्स इट डन गेट
लॉग इन अगर ये लॉग इन हो जाता बाय चांस तो
देयर इज अ सीएसआरएफ ठीक है वो सीएस आरफ
अवेलेबिलिटी है तो बस इस तरीके से आपको
ट्राई आउट करना है इसलिए मैं लाइव वेबसाइट
प ट्राई आउट करता हूं पहले लैब को पहले
कांसेप्ट समझा देता हूं आपको फिर लैब
सॉल्व कर देता हूं आपके लिए एक दो लैब
सॉल्व कर दिया आपके एग्जांपल के लिए एंड
फिर रियल वेबसाइट पे हम ट्राई आउट कर लेते
हैं कहीं कुछ मिल जाए तो ठीक है अदर वाइज
रियल वेबसाइट्स पे जरूरी नहीं है कि लाइव
आपको कुछ मिल ही जाएगा बट ऐसे बहुत सारी
वेबसाइट्स हैं जिस पर आप ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं जब आपको ऐसा कुछ मिलता है जस्ट
गो एंड रिपोर्ट देम ठीक है कुछ भी चेंज
अकाउंट के अंदर कोई भी फंक्शनैलिटी जो
चेंज आप कर सकते हैं ना ईमेल हो गया
पासवर्ड हो गया यूजर नेम हो गया प्रोफाइल
अपडेशन हो गई पेमेंट मेथड हो गया सब पे
ट्राई आपको करना है सबके रिक्वेस्ट को
कैप्चर करना है है सीएसआरएफ पीसी जनरेट
करना है सीएसआरएफ को बायपास करने का
अलग-अलग तरीकों को यूज करना है एंड देन यू
कैन ट्राई अब जैसे मैंने ये चीज तो कर ली
अब चलो मैं एक चीज और क्या कर
लूंगा कि एक तो
ऑथेंटिकेशन टोकन जो है ना इसको पूरा ही
रिमूव कर दूंगा
मैं पूरा ही रिमूव कर दिया ठीक है पूरा ही
रिमूव कर दिया एंड अब इसको चेंज कर दूंगा
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड को गेट पे कर दिया मैंने
गेट वाली पे कर दिया
दैट्ची जनरेट करूंगा सीएसआर
पसी ट जनरेट सीसर पीसी ना कॉपी द एटीएमएल
फाइल गो टू द सेम एचटीएमएल एडिटेट जस्ट
कॉपी द न्यू सीएस आरफ पीसी एंड जस्ट ओपन
सबमिट करो एंड अगर काम कर गया तो ठीक है
नहीं कर कोई बात
नहीं न्यू डट पासवर्ड यही था आई थिंक
पासवर्ड
हा सो लेट्स लॉग
इन नहीं है न्यू का एन कैपट एन स्मल तो
नहीं था न्यू पासवर्ड लेट्स ट्राई ट्राई
अगेन नहीं तो यह सीएसआरएफ वल्नरेबल नहीं
है फिलहाल के लिए एंड वी ट्राइड राइट तो
यह आपको समझ में आप सबको समझ में आया कि
क्या चीजें यहां पर हो रही है किस तरीके
से चीजें काम कर ही है एवरीवन गेटिंग ग इट
एवरीवन प्लीज मुझे बताइए जल्दी हां
पासवर्ड सही डाला है
मैंने हां पासवर्ड सही डाला है मैंने बट
आपको बस ट्राई देखो ट्राई करना अलग अलग
तरीके की सीस अब मैं जो आपको देखो जैसे
मैंने आपको एक टॉपिक बताया ठीक है मैंने
क्या किया आपको एक टॉपिक बताया अब उस
टॉपिक को एक्सप्लोर करके और भी डीप आपको
जाना है और भी अलग-अलग मेथड ट्राई करनी है
आपको ट्राई करना है कि और कौन-कौन से
तरीके से मैं इसको कर पा सकता हूं कर सकता
हूं यह आपको ट्राई करना है समझ में आ रहा
है एवरीवन
गेटिंग
जितने मेथोड जितने तरीके ट्राई कर सकते हो
करना बिकॉज वही बग बाउंट कहलाता है बग
बाउंट हंटर बनना अ इतना भी इजी नहीं है
लेकिन अगर आप अपनी डेडिकेशन दिखाते हो आप
अपनी कंसिस्टेंसी दिखाते हो हार्ड वर्क
करते हो ना तो आपको प्रो बनने से दुनिया
का कोई भी इंसान नहीं रोक सकता है एंड
जैसा मैंने देखा है
डुप्लीकेट्स भी मिल रहे हैं एंड दैट इज
दैट इज फैबुलस बहुत ही शानदार चीज है मेरे
मेरे हिसाब से तो ठीक है तो सीएसआरएफ के
लिए मजा आया समझ में आया सीएसआरएफ कंप्लीट
ठीक है एंड आई होप कि आप प्रैक्टिस करेंगे
इसकी बिना प्रैक्टिस किए कुछ नहीं होता है
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे तो ही कुछ हो पाएगा
प्रैक्टिस नहीं करेंगे तो फिर दिक्कत है
भाई याद
रखिएगा सर मेरे आज का सेशन समझ नहीं आया
थोड़ा सा बाउंसर जा सकता है आज का सेशन आज
का सेशन जिनको थोड़ा सा प्रॉब्लम हुआ हो
समझने में प्लीज मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा आप इस पर्टिकुलर वीडियो को सेशन
एंड होने के बाद वापस से रिपीट मोड में
देखिए ठीक है जरूर देखिए एंड
whatsapp2 की या फिर
तो आप वहां पे पूछ सकते हैं एक दूसरे से
डिस्कस कर सकते हैं तो आपके लिए काफी इजी
हो जाएगा राइट तो उसकी अनाउंसमेंट मैं
बहुत जल्द करने वाला हूं आप सब उसको जवाइन
कर लेना ओके
चलिए ओके
ग्रेट और सभी लोग जाना तो लाइक ठोक के
जाना यार 92 लाइक्स हुए हैं 100 तो करही
के जाना 93 हुए हैं 100 तो करके जाना
यार
ओके चलो चलो काफी दिनों बाद मिले थे सो आई
वाज वेरी एक्साइटेड एंड काफी मजा आया मुझे
भी आज के सेशन में क्योंकि काफी दिन हो गए
थे हम दोनों को हम हम लोगों को इंटरेक्ट
किए हुए एंड लाइव में मिले हुए अब ये
रेगुलर आएंगी आपकी एंड और भी बहुत कुछ
प्लान है जो आने वाली है रोनिक्स अकेडमी
youtube0 की क्लासेस चल रही हैं बहुत सारी
फ्री कोर्सेस ऑलरेडी इस चैनल पे हैं जिनको
काली लिनिक्स सीखना है उनके लिए भी यह
चैनल बिल्कुल चैनल यह आपका है जिनको काली
लिनिक्स भी सीखनी है ना भाई उसके लिए भी
मतलब हमारे डेनिक्स एकेडमी चैनल पे आपको
सिर्फ बग बाउंट ही नहीं बग बाउंट के अलावा
देयर आर मल्टीपल डोमेंस दैट वी हैव कवर्ड
बग बाउंट तो है ही साथ में आपको बैश जो है
वो आपको सीखने को मिलेगा बहुत ही डिटेल
में बैश को आप सीख सकते हैं साथ में
एसक्यूएल की एक क्विक मास्टर क्लास
क्लासेस आप कर सकते हैं जहां पे आपको
एसक्यूएल के बारे में आईडिया होगा पाइथन
के बारे में आप पढ़ सकते हैं पाइथन की
नॉलेज आपको हो जाएगी ओं के ऊपर में यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं 12 13 जो 13 वीडियोस
हैं एक वीडियो का एवरेज ड्यूरेशन एक घंटे
का है 13 14 घंटे का यह पूरा कंप्लीट फ्री
कोर्स है आप उसको देख सकते हैं एंड यहां
पे काली लिनिक्स की आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे 15 वीडियोस यहां पड़ी है जिसको आप देख
के काली नक्स को सीख सकते हैं तो बस इतना
ही आज के वीडियो के लिए गाइस आज की क्लास
के लिए आई होप कि आपको मजा आया होगा ठीक
है तो आ जाइएगा
इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग के साथ ठीक है थैंक यू
गाइस थैंक यू सो
मच